this show is brought to you by mvmt
watches get a watch just like mine at
mvmtwatches.com
and get
use code word church to get 15 off today
with free shipping and free returns
their watches start at five dollars or
to a department store you're looking at
over four hundred go to
mvmtwatches.com
church today to get 15 off with free
shipping and free returns
shows also brought to you by helix sleep
where you can buy mattresses online
customized for you for hundreds of
dollars instead of thousands
go to helixsleep.com
joey and get 50 off of your order that's
helixsleep.com joey
helixsleep.com joey
the show is brought to you by blue apron
where for less than ten dollars a meal
blue apron delivers seasonal recipes
along with the ingredients
to make them
please sound like a [ __ ] undertaker
tonight
you're bringing me bad news that's your
fault no no i love blue apron i just
made it last week this week i made a
couple great recipes i'm going to tell
you about them later
go to blueapron.com
right now check out this week's menu and
get your first three meals for free with
free shipping by going to blueapron.com
joey
this show is also brought to you by on
it
unbelievable
i thought he was reading me like that
here we go kick this [ __ ] muley kick
it i want this to blast my [ __ ] ears
off
we ain't [ __ ] around tonight you
understand me it's monday morning
[ __ ] uncle joey here with his goomba
lisa
rodrigo torres and my main man felipe
sparza what's up this is the [ __ ]
theme of the show right here 1980s elf
bent for leather delivering the [ __ ]
goods i'm sucker
oh [ __ ]
are you [ __ ] kidding me or what
judas priest with a gay singer he didn't
give a [ __ ] jack nobody gave a [ __ ] we
knew he was gay but what are you gonna
do i didn't know he was gay man
something about him i knew something he
had whipped him man
the first time i saw them he blew my
[ __ ] mind
he blew my [ __ ] mind like just took
it out of the like i was somewhere else
my mom had just died
i had the ticket what was i not gonna go
it was like two weeks after my mom died
let me go down there and i went over to
the i think it was the palladium
and everything it was this tour it was
this tour and the guy he came out with a
motorcycle with a whip
[ __ ] whipped the stage and i was like
what the [ __ ] is he doing the gay blade
and then he started singing metal gun oh
no he was singing hellbent for leather
or something and i was just sitting oh
jesus chris i didn't really like him i
was a black sabbath dude but after that
i went home and i bought the album and
it's all over you know what i'm saying
rodrigo oh yeah that's some good music
right there no it's that's a great album
i you know what it was deep deep deep in
the closet but like i told people you
gotta check your skeletons from time to
time
i checked the skeleton and i saw that
album and i said [ __ ] it killing machine
burning up it's got 20 good the green
manileshi it's got a bunch of [ __ ]
felipe sparza what's happening though oh
man when drew the priest came out man i
wanted to wear leather and those beads
i used to go to melrose man and try to
chop lift the little bands to wear
oh yeah man i don't know he was gay
though man jp baby
i used to have the hat judas priest and
the whole thing but all those years i
went to see him the first
three or four times i went to sam it was
a movie theater
they just destroyed the movie theater
def leopard destroyed a movie theater
they destroyed a movie theater now then
they got into arenas they said [ __ ]
let's take this to arenas who gives a
[ __ ] what it sounds like you know what
i'm saying so
that but i want to see them
priest iron maiden with the original
singapore diana oh damn movie killer's
record yeah it was a movie theater you
know so
what are you gonna do who gives a [ __ ]
at the end of the day when i'm gonna
cask it you think i'm gonna be thinking
about ac dc no
there was this guy on my little native
american kid named dean he was native
american primo papago shout out
this fool had all the iron maiden novels
bro he had and he was a little nerdy kid
little dirty kid
all his friend felipe you know i have
iron maiden albums yeah so i went to his
house bro and we played every album man
run through the hills yeah all that [ __ ]
how many hours was the other one just
one
uh i think just the first one killers
right because the rest of it's uh bruce
dickinson who's dickinson
yeah and then because i mean the only
one i really know is peace of mind then
they had like you know son of the seven
son and [ __ ] but all those [ __ ] i was
too i was gone by then
i
that's the second now man we had we had
this crazy teacher named mr roots in
english class and then he said um
everybody bring your favorite album and
then this crazy long-haired dude from
the stoners 13 he brought a iron maiden
number of the beast and the first song
we played was um the white man came
man we broke down that album and he was
like an old school hippie teacher from
kent high school where they shot that
kid at the kent university in ohio
yeah he was there he was at that college
so he was hardcore chicano mr root and
he broke down and the white man came
across the sea dude we only had one
white kid in there in the classroom
paul
he was a white kid named paul and then
every time he kept telling the story
about how the indians were slaughtered
by white people he kept looking at the
paw and then paul got up and said [ __ ]
you [ __ ]
how do you do [ __ ] i know huh
damn are you serious yeah all because of
iron maiden bro he ran to the hills
that's crazy [ __ ] [ __ ] love iron man
i knew kids bro that used to worship
ozzy dog
yeah man all that heavy metal [ __ ] dude
damn ac dc mad ass followers it's devil
music my mom was saying well ozzy
slipped into my life
like black sabbath slipped in when i
needed it the most
so all those years i really liked
sabbath coming up you know like i was
there
yeah that was my main [ __ ] band
that was my main [ __ ] band when he
came out with
the first solo album i nearly lost my
mind
which album was that the blizzard of oz
oh my god randy wrote
my mind like that was
you guys had the bass player on the show
right yeah in fact he was going to be on
tuesday he had a switch and
he's going to boston on wednesday
classic cash hit so but it's it's so
weird to see him sit here sometimes
sometimes you just go to lunch and i sit
across from him and for like the first
10 minutes i think about that whole
uh
that whole thing because
they came around like october of 79 and
they were just god awful
do you know when you see somebody you
ever going to see someone you go
this is the last time i see these guys
yeah there's some bands that you go see
now this was the first time i had seen
them
but in those days you never caught the
warm-up act
you know what i'm saying no way you
never caught your party in the parking
lot yeah you didn't have to be in there
till 8 30.
the warm-up band for this
concert was van halen and the word got
out do not miss
the [ __ ] warm-up man and he came out
with eruption
and then your head's blowing up
people committing suicide right there at
this [ __ ] mass square garden and they
had left with so much like they blew it
up and then ozzy came out hammered
you know we were sitting on the side and
i'll never forget this bill ward in
between songs
was taking something out and putting it
on the snare drum and they would take a
straw and snort it and put it back and
he would play the [ __ ] drums i mean
it was so in front of you you know ozzy
had bach in his hand drinking it they
sounded terrible and i remember leaving
there
i'm never going to see these guys again
like there was just some people who i
saw early on that were [ __ ] great
like the b-52s regret
they were great but then i went to see
aerosmith early on harold smith was bad
every time i went to see him anybody who
told you they went to see aerosmith
before 80 and they said they were great
they're lying to you they just paid too
much for their ticket and they can't go
back now
they scalp the ticket for like 80 and
they can't go all the concerts up they
won't do that they were so bad the last
time i saw iris smith they basically got
beat up off the stage
were they too [ __ ] up or what it was a
horror show
it was a horror show they were [ __ ] up
first time i saw him we walked to
meadowlands and it was
frank mourinho mahogany rush poco
[ __ ] ted nugent and aerosmith damn
that's good as bill eric smith went up
there and started playing uh last you
know you're excited for this [ __ ]
music
and it was a big place and it sounded
bad but you could tell they were high on
something
and then [ __ ] joe perry broke his
guitar and [ __ ] and we heard we listened
to ted for about
15 20 minutes but we had a curfew the
kids i was with had a [ __ ] curfew
so we had to walk home on um
when you go into the city and you're
driving on that turnpike route three we
were walking on route three cars were
doing [ __ ] haiti pastors and i
remember we barely made it to our homes
and we could still hear ted nugent's
guitar
like we walked three miles and you could
still hear ted nugent's guitar that's
when music was music but aerosmith was
so bad and the word kept getting out
joe perry left brad whitford left and
then they played at like a rock bar
next time you go home and you go george
take me to [ __ ] uh
chance dragon in and when you drag it in
go george take me to where aerosmith
played it's right down the block you go
come on
it was called the soap factory
and when after that last album when the
night lightning strikes it's got boom
boom
boom
whatever happened
nobody can name
a song from that album that's how bad
the album is i personally like the
[ __ ] nightmare rutz
that's the name of the album we went to
see them
that dude was so [ __ ] up the singer
he was so [ __ ] up [ __ ] stephen adler
and [ __ ] guns and roses in the 90s
this guy was gone on stage heroin he was
singing to the walls he was skinny
you could see the bones through the
shirt you know it was just a [ __ ]
mess and he would light cigarettes and
flick him
he kept lighting cigarettes and flick
them now i got my own thing going on the
side
i mean
it was 15 10 general admission right so
whenever you got there you got it
me and my buddy get there a little early
and it's hot out it's humid
so there's women with halter tops
and there's guys smoking cigarettes are
you with me
so i'm 15 feet from the stage and guess
who's in front of me
a real deal heroin junkie
what's he doing he's lighting a
cigarette and a middle little thing he
puts the cigarette out right here he
leaves it six inches from his face and
he would start to nod
and as he would nod i'd push him into a
girl and they would burn her back
hysterical i'm doing this for 15-20
minutes by myself
and they're like stop it [ __ ] ass and
he's like i'm sorry i'm sorry people
keep bumping into me and every time he
and then he would move over like a foot
or two because he was finding out he
knew somebody behind damn kept pushing
him and every time he did not lisa lease
in the cult jam
right here when he was at this position
with the cigarette up i just push him
into somebody
and you hear the girl go ah
little hair burning this went on for 20
30 minutes the concert started it was so
boring me and my buddy like having our
own [ __ ] great time we did this
and finally he got so high the guy that
he just passed out
like he just fell and people just
started stepping on him and people stood
there the whole night he was on the
floor
this guy was so high on heroin he was
just laying there
man so now we're there jumping give us
some music he's lighting cigarettes and
flicking them at chicks
and he has microphones he has
handkerchiefs on his microphone okay
so we're in about an hour now
and he's saying and he's [ __ ] up the
words it's like sinatra if you went to
see sinatra in the 80s bro he had no
idea what the words were
his even with the teleprompter he would
not have an idea what he was saying but
police etho you know but this guy was so
inebriated
and he was just singing different songs
and the band was looking at him and
and then he started taking on the
audience
and he would light the cigarettes and
flick them somebody threw a joint
and that's hello and that's where it got
ugly he lit it took two hits and flicked
it and it burnt one of the girls here i
am burning women for an hour and he
decides to flick a joint and burn a
chick they start yelling [ __ ] you he's
like [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
he's holding on to the microphone
singing a song and they start tugging on
his
handkerchief on his handkerchief and
he's going back and forth
this goes on for like three [ __ ]
minutes and i knew one of the kids mike
ascalis i still talk to them on the
phone from time to time they're going
back and forth back and forth back and
forth finally he throws the microphone
and dives in headfirst that was it you
don't do that in new jersey they don't
give a [ __ ] who you are punches he's on
top of the audience and punches were hit
them in the face
they're just punching steven tyler
they're just clocking stephen tyler
finally security couldn't get into the
audience they wouldn't let him
security from the stage had to grab his
[ __ ] neck by the shirt and rip him up
and i'll never forget he's in mid-flight
and it's like a step for them and
somebody just comes up to him and hits
him again
perfect they pulled him up and he ran to
the back the concert was over no more
[ __ ] aerosmith three weeks later they
were done
stuff like that
done you didn't hear from aerosmith
nothing and one day i'm in
aspen colorado
eating a quaalude i'm in a hotel across
the street from the in-n-out sandwich
place not the in-n-out hamburger place
this is the internet i ended up robbing
them too
i had a bill in there one day i said
that i saw the guy didn't make deposits
and they left the wind the door open had
one lock with the thing you know like
with the vent yeah open are you kidding
me in those days i was an acrobatic i
was 19. that was that's an invitation
for uncle joe i just jumped up and
kicked the window and went right through
and the next day they knew it was me but
i stayed at that little austrian hotel
there and i'm sitting there watching mtv
and [ __ ] whatever comes up and she
goes bro i'm here at a high school in
boston aerosmith is
and i'm like no they're not back and
they were jamming dog
they were clean and sober and they put
the camera on them they interviewed them
i had [ __ ] goose bumps
i'm like there's no way these guys are
back
but like two years later like the last
summer i went to see [ __ ]
joe perry put a band together the joe
perry project
and heart was opening up for him at
radio city so i went down there and i
was all quayluted up and the skinny
blonde was like 10 feet from me and i
grabbed the ankle and they told me they
went to throw me out but then the
security guy was cool he let me sit in
the back with the
with the [ __ ] up people and [ __ ]
grabbed the ankle i grabbed their ankles
dog those quails do some weird things to
you has bill cosby and [ __ ]
so this [ __ ] quit for a while
or what aerosmith run dmc brought them
back done
done then they put an album called done
with mirrors that is so bad you can't
find them they're done done with mirrors
it was so bad it was like three songs
from everest
and the songs that joe perry had
released they re-released them
the album is horrible it won't even play
if you find it when i saw them on their
movie sergeant pepper lonely heart club
band i said who is this band because i
never i don't know who they were
and they were singing um
a beatles song on sergeant peppa lonely
hearts of bands like a bj's movie
yeah come together come together and
[ __ ] run the emcee
how crazy is that
they were gone all right they were done
they were done they were rehearsing but
this wasn't going up listen bro they
were clean and sober they couldn't they
couldn't write a song to [ __ ]
and then that's why they went to ballads
like somebody started writing balance
last time remember they did they did
what's that jam they did the movie
even when i closed my eyes
lee likes that he sings that to his
girlfriend what is that from uh that's
from uh armageddon yeah armageddon they
did that
but jamie's got a gun is good that album
is good
87 that was good 87 88 that whole
[ __ ] i mean not the whole album but
it's got its moments but it's it's now
dude looks like a lady
you know but they it ain't [ __ ] get
your wings
it ain't [ __ ] rocks no
no no no no no no no no no not even
close you could smell when you put rocks
on with a needle like i'll get rocks
right now put on you can smell heroin i
feel like the fourth song you start
getting high and [ __ ] that's how much
[ __ ] h they did for that album
is
raw that scott that album's got two
songs that are just pure heroine you
hear him she feeds the soul it's like
when you hear alice in change
uh i heard uh
freaked uh what's that the the the freak
the the freak whatever the other day i
was driving i'm like if this is heroin
this is beat the freak what's it called
lee let's see hold on [ __ ] amazing
jam freak show no uh alice in chains
something to the freak i forget lead the
freak bleed to freak god damn
you could smell the heroin in your car
you're like i better not get pulled over
i think i got chinese people in the
trunk and [ __ ] yelling and screaming a
power a tower
what's up felipe what's up fool any good
movies lately oh man a lot of good
movies man therefore
i was smoking dope but i had an idea of
a lifetime
okay
see the manager thinks like i think
manager
how much did you like jax teller the
truth
jax teller what's that
sons of anarchy
the show i'm trying to get [ __ ] on
over here oh dude sounds like i love
sounds they don't they do
they're doing two spin-offs but for some
reason i fell in love with jax teller
whatever his name is charlie hoonin he
played a gay guy on the other show
and when i seen him in sons of hanukkah
i don't think sons of hanukkah is the
greatest show in the world but i see
this kid
sons anarchy has been off for two
[ __ ] years in my life two years yeah
two years where is this kid
nothing nothing so two years he hasn't
done a [ __ ] thing they got him
scheduled to play a mexican with blue
eyes a drug dealer yeah a famous drug
dealer
yeah he's coming out with some other
[ __ ] movie about prehistoric things
that nobody cares about they're wasting
this motherfucker's time so you know me
dawg i'm sitting there smoking 50 shades
of gray he was supposed to be he said
yeah he turned it down yeah and he would
have been perfectly dirty so i'm sitting
there thinking the other day i always
ask my he's at my agency he's with a
different division he's [ __ ]
[ __ ] but i asked my agent when they go
what the [ __ ] is up with his agent do
you ever talk to him because yeah i know
him well i go how come this kid not
doing 20 [ __ ] movies then i sat there
like oh this kid had a movie star and
the movies and tv are too [ __ ]
different yeah okay two different
[ __ ] animals jack's tail is already
on [ __ ] fx
he's already on fx
and netflix i'll tell you what i'm gonna
do i'm gonna go [ __ ] put together a
treatment
of the mechanic
oh yeah and i'm gonna play charles
bronson and die in the third episode
like [ __ ] it just shoot me because it's
really his show yeah it's really jan
michael vincent's show you know what i'm
saying have you ever seen the mechanic
with jeff michael vincent what do you
look like when he shot that movie oh
yeah badass man so i'm thinking
see the mechanic remake the reason why i
got really mad at the remake of the
movie first of all don't [ __ ] with
charles bronson oh yeah leave that
[ __ ] man alone do not retouch his
movies leave him alone they're all gonna
die in hell they're all gonna this 12
[ __ ] the dirty dozen remake with the
cowboys and magnificent seven that is
not right that is not right at all i
won't even
i am pissed at them
no no [ __ ] you could tell that movie's
just god [ __ ] awful first of all
that's a [ __ ] japanese movie
i walked out of the audition did you
really no oh that's a joke that's how
bad it was no dog i wouldn't even want
to read for that i'm done i'm done i'm
done i'd rather do the podcast and go on
the road i'm done i don't want to read
for that [ __ ] no more because that's
just embarrassing that's just
embarrassing i did the longest yard i
came out smelling like a rose and i
moved the [ __ ] out
you know what i'm saying somebody gave
me a coat if the movie would have died i
would have been in bad shape but the
movie did well some people still hire me
because of it i don't say nothing i got
a call to do another movie i'm shooting
in north hollywood
this november 28th to december 17th
they just called me up how did you
manage that you don't know you don't
even have to like get a hotel
how [ __ ] up is god
i'm thinking about you have a sea scar
face yeah scarface was on the other
night and it's eight o'clock and i'm
going through the things the babies in
the room on you and i pressed the
[ __ ] thing and it's just starting
and that dude that puts the thing to his
face and says how did you get the scar
on your face
eating [ __ ] i did a movie with that
dude but when i did the movie to do to
do head glaucoma already he was
his wife had just died a beautiful man
he taught me more about acting in that
[ __ ] movie we did some movie together
and in fact me and the director and his
girlfriend got into a fight on the set
nobody talked to me for three weeks
it was [ __ ] horrible but guess what i
had the [ __ ] i had him on the [ __ ]
podcast
it wasn't a great podcast paul t murray
oh okay so the other day i'm watching
scarface and i wonder what happened to
old man john look i was going to church
with john
he's one of those old guys that you talk
to and you go i gotta do what this
[ __ ] is doing he was in dog day
afternoon anything that guy did he was
in so dog day afternoon scarface
anything that guy did the guy would just
call him and give him a roll some rolls
were big some rolls were small in
scarface he goes john i got a little
rophy
he goes go in there
pacino's in there and ask him this
question you know how'd you get the scar
on your face beautiful old man he just
you know those old man that you look and
you go this [ __ ] i used to smoke
dope in the car with him before church
and he would finally go get me ahead of
that [ __ ] he was one of those dudes and
we used to go to the philippines sacred
heart on wednesdays and he used to go
why are all these chicks here
and he didn't know pacquiao was there
pacquiao used to go to church there on
wednesdays we used to just happen to go
on wednesdays and we used to go in and
then i took him and then he took me to
another one in santa monica boulevard
and right in the middle of church he
goes there's too many [ __ ] gays here
we gotta go
i was like oh my god i met the perfect
old man old school dog you know i don't
have a granddad but if i did i wanted
that dude anyway why talk about
the reason why i had a mom there felipe
he told me a story he goes i get a call
to go down there and audition with al
pacino i just know al pacino from needle
park and i saw him in new york a couple
i don't know this kid he's supposed to
be a tremendous actor i get to the
audition and they say put a knife to his
face
so he comes in he goes first of all his
script
looked like it had gone through a
shredder
he goes that's what that dude does but
you know he goes his script looked like
he had ripped it apart
and put notes and glued it back together
and headshots
rewrote it just dissected it he goes he
came in
the director goes do it john he goes
why'd you get that scar on your face
eating [ __ ] goes cut cut john come
outside please john don't touch his
[ __ ] face that's the are you kidding
me don't touch his face that's the money
it's the stuff that's the money how can
you touch his [ __ ] face go in and
apologize
john goes in mr pacino i'm sorry i
touched your face he goes no no it's the
roll
with that they do action and he does it
again
and now he gets a call john they want to
see outside the producer and he'd come
pulls him inside he goes
how come you're not touching his [ __ ]
face put that knife in his [ __ ]
eyeball take his eye out and he goes the
director said no
i'm the one that's signing [ __ ]
checks here okay i want that knife and
his [ __ ] eyeball either the palmer
the palmer no no whatever the producer
was yeah wherever the director was the i
don't know i don't know that hey i was
talking with a guy now in the hotel room
when i was like joey medina
no the guy that talks from an
immigration oh that guy there's two guys
that talk about that he has one guy
standing and there's one guy sitting the
guy comes over and puts the knife on his
[ __ ] face yeah he said yeah what'd
you think when you first how old when
you first saw that movie oh man it was
1984 so how old were you i was like 14
were you doing below
hell and i wasn't doing nothing man i
loved it you were thinking about it hell
no i didn't even know what that was yet
but we went to why we have friends in
burbank and my dad was our cousin we
went over there and they made a bunch of
ceviche bro like a big bucket of ceviche
and we all sat down all the little kids
all the grown-ups and we all saw
scarface on vhs for three hours we saw
the whole movie
and i was like the first something i
didn't get it you know but i started
watching it i started saying that that's
a lot of [ __ ] money man
and i'm like my dad's my friend were
making dogs
my dad and him loved the movie though
man
they loved it
how old were you the first time you saw
it i was little dude it was probably
like a year came after we've seen it on
vhs but i didn't understand what's going
on
one night coming at the same suit as
john travolta and um saturday night
fever
how were you when you saw it lately last
year no i was probably like i was
probably like 16 or 17. and did you want
to go and do a little
and get your life together
when i was doing a lot of blow
during myspace days and i wanted to see
who wanted a party and i would tweet on
my facebook and i would tweet um
my update would be um who's up right now
hit him anybody watching scarface
and then that's how i know people were
doing blow tonight maybe literally
they'll be inviting me to their house to
the party or something
they'll come over crazy that was a cold
bro
anybody watching scarface right now
four in the morning hand hint
but now you can just put a little nose
with a 100
little pile but when i saw it later on
when i was up when i was like
selling crack you know in my
neighborhood
it gave me a sense of power bro to watch
that movie like yeah if we can make it i
can make it but now when i watch it i
see it that you know
you you can make it you know even if
you're not a cocaine dealer you know it
was a sign you know you come here you
work real hard no matter what you do you
could be a survivor bro well yeah but he
just chose that life
but man it's hard to watch sometimes you
know because the
some of those parts where he's dealing
with the mom is so real you know like
he thought you know like he could
impress his mom with money and the suit
and she's still saying get the [ __ ] out
of here man it hurts man i was pushing
drugs dog that's why
but she didn't know her
[ __ ] we never had a father [ __ ] she
knows something was up
that [ __ ] was that movie was [ __ ]
brutal dawg
you know those cubans that came over in
79 it was uh
it was you know
somebody's got to do a documentary of
the jail they let him out of
like you know what i'm saying like just
walk through that jail they were in
american jail if they didn't feed you on
time there's no feeding at seven
they would come in and throw a [ __ ]
piece of bread at your dog oh they would
throw like a sandwich into a cell with
four of us
you know and no showers because those
are the dirty hardcore criminals yeah
right the mariana boat project was so it
was really weird i saw the
transformation
i saw it right in front you know
it's so weird how i was doing mescaline
one day and having a great time with 20
kids
and all of a sudden nobody's doing
mexico anymore you know it went from you
needed five dollars to get high you
needed 250 for a hit of masculine and
250 we could chip in for a six-pack you
needed three four beers and i hit a
mescal and somebody had a joint you were
good to go rodrigo and all of a sudden
it went from that to people having to
spend 50
you know there was no sample of cocaine
if you really think the impact that this
had on the economy here
you really have to think about 1978 77 i
saw it
i saw people talking it was spoken in my
house since i was a kid
but i was starting to see it more now
i was starting to see it i knew my mom
had white rings around her nose i knew
what time it was i wasn't [ __ ]
but now i was hearing people talking
about it it was in the clubs
the kids older than me were coming back
going no no no
now i was in shock i just thought my mom
and her friends did it
do you follow me so now i had to sit
there with my tongue tied i could you
ever done it no i don't know what you're
talking about how old were you
13 damn
so 13
it's
1976. and it was already creeping
77 staying alive quality and cocaine
78 79 was the first time
i had some
and it was in a draw and it sat in that
[ __ ] draw for months
and then i went to a party one day i
decided to take it i knew i was gonna i
was gonna sell it
but i said [ __ ] it i did it and i didn't
you know the first year i did blow it
didn't get me off
i thought people were lying to me like
cyanide live
you know for years people told me it was
so funny i'd go home and i wouldn't
laugh maybe with flowers and a bunch of
people were laughing
and i wouldn't laugh with coke i would
do coke with people i'd see them getting
all twisted and hiding and [ __ ] and
nothing was happening to me until one
day i had a cocktail uh-oh see i didn't
drink one day i had a beer and i'm like
oh that [ __ ] clicked my jaw is clicking
my fingers again like i'm a piano player
[ __ ] this party's on this [ __ ]
you were like jeff's done with no
puppets and then they dropped scarface
on these kids yeah man
it was like taking a generation to
vietnam you had to see it like i [ __ ]
saw it like i saw kids that were decent
kids and i'd see them in a bar at four
in the morning like [ __ ] lucifer
and i would go oh [ __ ]
and then they weren't smoking crack yet
there was no crack yet like i was still
83 84 everybody had it in 83 if you
bumped into the manager she'd pull you
aside and go listen
a friend of mine
left me a kilo
do you know anybody who could sell it he
said we could make a lot of money you
were bumping into people like that like
your neighbor would come over and go dog
do you know anything about cocaine it
was everywhere it was everywhere
everybody had it eighteen hundred an
ounce a hundred a gram or don't even
talk to me
sixty a half a gram how good was it it
was right off the [ __ ] shipment they
were [ __ ] piling in here it was glass
it was [ __ ] glass first time i went
to miami in 84 nobody jawed you didn't
stay up
you didn't stay up your eyes got red
like those red veins were in your eyes
you got all red and [ __ ] and you get
high and your dick got hard and you had
a good [ __ ] time and you were last
night
then over the years when you started
getting they just started doing
something to it putting speed in there
the rat poison aspirations and that's
and then strictly in 84
85 people were smoking it in cigarettes
and clubs i went to the city in 85. i
was not doing drugs at this time and
people were already the colombians they
would go that's a columbian table and
you could smell the coke in here
and they were putting it in [ __ ]
cigarettes
and then
i went over to the city
to get weed one day
manager i've been going to response
since i was [ __ ] 13 14.
it was 148th and broadway
were you sure these weed stores today
yeah
listen
i was i copped there from [ __ ] 77
to 84 and a half
and then i just started coupling jersey
or we were coping 178th street but if i
was 140 and i was in labor and i'd go
there it was called the master mix
the guy was right on the stoop
stoop he was on the stoop little pigeon
what up soldier
green weed that you never saw then
nobody had green wheat damn it was all
the weed from jamaica up in harlem the
master mix it was the buddha thai the
chocolate pie everybody had chocolate
tie he had green weed and then he put it
together and that was called
the master mix
and guess what he gave you a [ __ ]
punch card
in 19 [ __ ] 80 homie was already
giving you a punch what did it say on it
if you bought ten nickel bags you got
one for it was ten dollar bags if you
bought ten ten dollar bags you got one
for free
who the [ __ ] you think you're dealing
with this is on the street no license no
nothing i went there and they go weed we
don't sell weed no more it's cracked
cracked it was gone and gone the little
vials were all over the street
and i had never seen that before
and then i went to colorado in colorado
i heard about crack people cracked up
and [ __ ]
when i grew up like the biggest thing i
ever saw was weed and alcohol i'm sure
that there maybe there were pills or
something and maybe there were some kids
who did other stuff but
did you ever have people did you have
anyone who is negative about cocaine in
your life or was everyone like a really
pilot it hit so hardly
in 1982 it hit so hard
like girls that you knew that were
cheerleaders that [ __ ] cyo basketball
at the prom with doing [ __ ] powder oh
my god
you know what i'm saying like that it
would it hit that hard like if you were
at a party
and there was ten people that nine and
and those see
in the beginning cocaine didn't take
over as a drug that got people high
cocaine put you in a different class
the only people with money could [ __ ]
that desert rat
that desert rat from [ __ ] glendale
that [ __ ] everybody when she was eight
she's somebody now
you walk into a bathroom you do two
lines you come out and the whole room
will look at you
that's how you get people's likes out of
the 80s by going the whole room we're
looking and they come up to you all
creepy have you done coke how is it
how's the drip tell me the truth can i
get a little bump from you it was
[ __ ] insane
it was [ __ ] insane but that's how
they sold it
that's how they sold it it didn't they
didn't sell it because it was a great
drug you dunk coconut [ __ ] dick after
you see it ain't dick
they sold it you became a bigger person
you were doing what the movie stars
though
you know what i'm saying it was the
convertible and then [ __ ] harry
clapton then black sabbath and that was
it go king that was it
it hit like the one line 10 years ago
you wouldn't see a weed store
now you see a weed store every two
[ __ ] blocks that's what it was
everybody had coke for sale everybody
had it
everybody could give it to you on the
arm because they had so much of it in
the house
people go do you know anybody who buys
coke and you go no not really meanwhile
you haven't done coke in two days you
got a monkey in your back his asshole's
on fire you know what i'm saying
i don't know nobody let me give you an
ounce if you could sell it sell it and
not bring it back what
you ain't ever gonna see me
but then crack took over and that i
don't know how was it here oh man
same same time like like 82 83
selling pure thai stick at the little
corner
on clearance street and boyle heights
and the projects pico aliso it was
called the thailand because all they saw
was thai stick people drive by and they
have these long sticks with marijuana
stuck to it and they will start out to
their cars and then one day man
everybody started suddenly crack instead
of tie sticks
and then you started seeing these young
14 year old kid with little big gold
chains
and beepers that was the first sign that
i saw a young kid wearing a beeper i
said damn
this was a doctor or what
and um everybody was standing crack man
everybody it wasn't like um
it wasn't like it is now where ever you
got to pay taxes to somebody you know or
the neighborhood is controlled by
another by some gang
it was like open it was like the wawa
west in my neighborhood man and they
stole a lot of pcp too
another spot
but man i remember
crack was crazy man when it first came
along
it was crazy crazy right right it just
took people to the next level man like
it'll just kill a whole family man like
instant addiction right you can make
more more crack out of a little bit of
cocaine i got hooked on a crack in
hollywood
for six weeks i was smoking crack i'd
buy it right by the theater by man's
chinese theater around that corner be
two black guys we'd make eye contact
they beat me they beat me [ __ ] ten times
they'd sell me soap these [ __ ] suckers
my fingers were always dirty and [ __ ] my
wife would wake up what is that [ __ ]
smell the weed go back to bed
i would smoke it out of a coke can
that's hardly [ __ ] then i went to a
basket there was no crack so i got poked
back on the coke and i didn't smoke
crack again
tremendous how addictions transferring
[ __ ] like that i didn't smoke crack i
never thought i'd smoke crackers me
neither i didn't like listen in 82.
freebase was getting big
that different from crack
right
bro it was [ __ ] stupid white people
they wasted my [ __ ] time wasting my
[ __ ] time okay and timmy there's a
kid who listens to the podcast timmy
holloway my buddy
me him
me him
and
this this black dude a friend of mine
came up to me when he goes bro i heard
you got good coke i just graduated high
school yeah i could hook you up because
dog i sell coke to pimps because i got
these pimps down in jersey city and
whatever that will buy coke for you we
got to go down to the hotel but the guy
that was going
that's where i got the word tremendous
from everything in this kid's life you
he'd say tremendous how's the how are
the girls tremendous
how's the coke tremendous how was that
right turn tremendous he would even tell
you that right turn was tremendous
so we went that steve atlantis i don't i
forget what the [ __ ] his name was dawg
tremendous we went to this hotel room
it's the summer of 82 i'm getting my
coke from a high school teacher
but now since we were out of high school
he would tell us mr belding huh no i
don't know if it's mr belvedere it's the
camel let's just call him camel breath
because he used to smoke camel cigarette
camo filter and his cigarette was orange
from the camera cigarettes tremendous so
cameron breath he would sell you the
coke already in the [ __ ] bindle so we
went down to those pimps i gave him a
couple grams here's the code we still
got the f in his final what's that no no
we were out of school he wouldn't [ __ ]
with us then and the pimp was like dog
have you ever free base
and i go no but we'll give it a shot he
did the whole thing he had his all his
hookers there and they were like he was
a magician
and he did it but he had like the silk
scarf and [ __ ] you know
he was like
he was like orange juice jones and [ __ ]
and he would tell the [ __ ] you ain't
getting them you hook a [ __ ]
and me him and the other two people
smoked it and it wasn't bad and there's
a place again next time you go back to
the caroline tell george joey said take
me to
east west east west east west is a head
start that's been there
it says gossip
from 1970 when i was a kid i used to go
in and buy uh when people go to a tape
recorder to a concert yes whatever those
are called remember that [ __ ] in the 70s
real quick not bootlegs yeah bootleg
bootlegs people go
if the stones played six nights in the
garden you would go all six nights and
they'd get one show and but they also
had a how to make [ __ ]
freebase kit for 49
no way so i bought it i took it home it
was butane
a glass a silk scarf
a ton of [ __ ] and then you we went home
we went to my friend's house devo
we when i woke up in the morning all the
bottles were turned upside down there
was like 15. we went through 15 grams
and like at the end the next day i said
what did we do first of all you got to
sit there and cook it and become a
chemist
it's white people [ __ ] i'm sorry manager
it's white people just too much thought
just give it to me guys give me that
[ __ ] mule yeah
let's get that joe going give me a
little freeze i got a cavity back here
let's get this [ __ ] yeah let's get the
bolivian
bang going
but you can't do that no more we got to
be decent people we got to respect
ourselves we got to be comedians and
[ __ ] stop not shop notch man you know
what i'm saying if you want to get to
the top you can't bring that meal with
you
so as long as you know that going in it
all works out for you you should like
that you remember the first time i tried
crack i liked it man
i heard it's [ __ ] instantly addictive
i've never heard anybody that junk
cracked and say that [ __ ] sucks
everybody says super [ __ ] good
i didn't listen at that point the point
in my life when i was smoking crack it
was like 98.
i didn't really give a [ __ ] jack he's
like [ __ ] it oh yeah and some of the
nights i would smoke it even if i knew
it wasn't crack
i would just smoke it because i bought
it i might as well get my money out of
this this thing tastes like saran wrap
and [ __ ] i smoking all men and [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] terrible terrible [ __ ] you do
when you're in that level yeah man you
don't know when you're in that [ __ ]
level you're [ __ ] creeping man
you're giving money to somebody and
hopefully they'll come back
yo i'll be right back and [ __ ] right
back
you're there for three hours that's the
worst that is [ __ ] four in the
morning on seventh and spring a little
pincher [ __ ] too if they'll come back
i'm at this drug deal
by mistake
i meet him by chance but this guy was so
[ __ ] good he was at the end of my
journey
he was at the end of my cocaine journey
he was like
i put him into the rotation
the problem was i didn't have his phone
number
i didn't have a way how to get a hold of
him his cocaine was the best at all the
coke i was buying d-money el compadre i
had three or four yeah
john blaze
martel cartel martel cartel wanna tell
cartel was good but i had to [ __ ]
shake him down because they'd sell me
this [ __ ] they selling the [ __ ] white
people give me the real meal in the back
that uncut [ __ ] in the [ __ ] thing he
was cutting it like 20 the [ __ ] 10
the martell cartel until i showed up and
said you can't do that stepping on it
like i can't do this [ __ ] you're a
marginalized april so
towards the end one night i pull into
compadre
and i get a tap in my window
and i zip the window down
and the guy goes that way
i have a present for you and i look at
him i go really i think he's gonna
[ __ ] shoot me
i thought he's gonna [ __ ] shoot me i
thought the gun was right there don't
mind he takes out like a savage
you know how decent people go let's go
to a bathroom can i get that car
he don't give a [ __ ]
he takes out this brown bag
that's wrapped and he goes in it and he
goes out of the way
no permission no nothing he puts the
rock in my nose
he goes away
and i'm like
yeah and i'm like trying to [ __ ] where
the [ __ ] do i know you from who comes up
to you and puts a coke rock and first of
all what the [ __ ] do i know he's talking
to me he's not poisoning me he's talking
away and i'm looking at him like i don't
know who the [ __ ] this guy is but this
coke's on fire like i'm already my
throat's dry and [ __ ]
and i said to him getting money go see
him get him i go give me a 60. just to
see what he was playing
no scale
no no [ __ ] he went in that little
magician bag give me some love he took
out a boulder and just handed it to me
like i'm like you have any paper or no
handle even though iceberg nothing bro i
had to put in the thing find paper hide
it and i pulled out of there and that
was it
okay
i go back to el compadre maybe two three
weeks later i'm asking around is there
another guy that just walks around did i
just hallucinate some guys imagine a
magician here
where's el musical the man with the rock
i don't see this guy
i don't see this guy ever again
and then i ended up doing one of those
three comedy show nights
you know uh
la casa rosa would fly oh cause of
latino and then shoot over to jeff
garcia's and do that one for 50. and
then shoot over to philippe's felipe we
have 75 for me so some nights
there'd be too much traffic on the 101
and i get off on sunset
right and one night i got outside and
said ah minding my own business you know
i'm a little agitated i can't get no
drugs it's already one o'clock the
[ __ ] laker game [ __ ] that [ __ ] up you
know what i'm saying
and one night i'm at the light by
western and sunset and i'm hearing like
hey pay it out
on i'm looking around hey who do i see
but the mexican running up to the car
the coke ferry yeah the coke ferry run
runs up to like there's like a burger
king on the corner and there's like a
construction thing in there and then
they sprint and then there's like uh
blaze pizza you know you guys know what
i'm talking about yeah man you know what
i'm talking about western sunset right
there there's a mcdonald's or some
shitty place he lurks in those trees
so he comes up to me at the light one
o'clock in the morning sunset boulevard
is this way and i'm like oh my god
you showed up when i hated you
before i could say a word ba-boom puts a
rock in my nose again again
again at the light at the light like he
owned [ __ ] western sunset
he goes okay get his way i just took out
everything i had give it to me he just
took out a [ __ ] boulder
i remember driving home
with the coke rock in my hand like a
[ __ ] another i say that joke on stage
it's not a joke
i drove home with like ram and three
quarter rock on my hand
just driving home with the air
conditioning around lightly and the
fumes hit my face tremendous and i said
to him how do i get a hold of you and he
goes just come here at night i'm here
from 12 all night i go where he goes
just drive up and down like once or
twice i'll come out of the tree
okay
better [ __ ]
that surface
where's tony bennett oh okay oh my god
this [ __ ] sometimes that one time
said uh every time i looked at the coke
rock it got bigger oh yeah
hell yeah
i always been like that i'm one time i
hope that um i want to be around i was
at this bar and i was loaded and that
guy goes you want a bump
it's a good look bart man the good luck
bar right there on
hollywood
returns
i went to the bathroom and he gave me a
long line of
i thought it was coke but it was meth
after i was done i was just by myself
bro listening to one
music by myself awake no beer nothing
bro i cleaned the whole house i got a
little toothbrush bro and i've cleaned
the edge of the everything details
raiders one baby
30 to 20 we're in first place
to las vegas now
i'm going to the games
pick up a gig on saturday and watch the
game on sunday
you know it's crazy when i moved here
i thought i was going to hide my
addiction
like i'm like i'm not going to find
nobody to tommy store the improv that's
got blow the third night i think i got a
package
i was so ashamed of myself like i'm like
i can't [ __ ] believe this i'm in l.a
and i'm getting packages the third day
this ain't gonna [ __ ] go nowhere you
know what i'm saying like this is
i always thought when i come to l.a i
wouldn't find somebody for like a year
and by that time who the [ __ ] wanted to
do it you know
but life uh always throws a different
curve up all that what's going on with
you mr attorney when are we getting the
[ __ ] degree here
i haven't been to school in two years
two years already huh it's been already
two years ago yeah go online can we go
on phoenix and just finish this [ __ ]
thing
contract law hollywood law
contract agent whatever you can start
you the beautiful thing about that stuff
just as long as you your paypal and you
start doing contracts we can make a
living with you everybody needs to look
at a [ __ ] contract stop flipping
houses that's it flipping [ __ ]
contracts
when you're an attorney you could do so
many [ __ ] things especially in this
town
you could be a manager you could [ __ ]
you know
look around for people who slip and fall
you know what i'm saying there's so many
ambulances you could defend the [ __ ]
drug deal
call me now siable espanol but i said
number two by the way i told you
[ __ ] last week if you're trying
to get unemployment or you're calling
for an airline ticket or anything that
offers you do you want this line in
spanish always press that line it don't
matter they're still gonna talk to you
you're gonna have to wait forever they
don't want to piss off spanish people a
little [ __ ] tip for you from uncle
joey all right because they're not gonna
hang up on you because you're not
spanish tell me you're deaf dumb the
music was on you don't know what the
[ __ ] they're saying you just pressed two
by mistake but we're here now let's
handle this situation my vacuum broke
what's going on you bad [ __ ]
felipe
i'm going to be on superstore this
thursday man what's superstar superstore
and nbc with american ferrara okay look
at you um it's called on the the uh it's
called superstore on nbc at eight
o'clock on thursday it's my second time
on a row a recurring role named cody
look at you you and i have discussed the
acting thing yes and it's finally coming
to fruition it took a while you never
know when it's going to strike in this
time most people at home jerking off
right now
you got two [ __ ] episodes
south tape myself rodrigo torres and
adam murray you didn't know that rodrigo
was a brilliant [ __ ] camera dude
you know how the whole is steady
i remember rodrigo's brother edited a
video for rancho bob he wanted to make a
video of a cat he kept bugging me what
can i do with the video
and all right come on back let's make
this reach him
he shot the video and didn't edit it at
all and gave me the [ __ ] video your
brother was a beauty
and i hired him to take my head shots it
was only one picture
he duplicated it was the same ugly
picture i was like now i get why you get
photographers and [ __ ]
he wanted to be tarantino he had the
original script for a [ __ ] uh mulatto
what's his name
he had the original script his brother
wanted to breed horses in the backyard
his father his father said hell no
ain't no horses gonna fit back there too
he used to get pissed off he's a beauty
he's a beard
poor roncho he's a beauty and [ __ ]
who did we get [ __ ] all you that did
me on those edibles that had to be ten
years ago rodrigo
was eight he was out
yeah it was two thousand two thousand
six
right there at the boxing gym yeah the
boxing jump out with you you used to go
to that spice company
that big dude always hook you with that
big ass bubble
and it was i ate a whole candy bar we
went there on tuesdays that was cushman
had a deal no before cushmar was on uh
hollywood we had a deal with this dude
the guy's name was dave in fact i just
bumped into him maybe about 18 months
ago he runs a barbecue bar in uh burbank
i wanted to watch at ufc with a friend
of mine and he came over and said hello
he was a real interesting guy he was a
chef
and when the edible craze came out he
tried it at his restaurant and this guy
hired him and this guy made he was one
of the original guys that was making
really tasty chocolate
like whatever he gave you like got like
the best thing he ever made was
non-perel's
really nice holy jesus christ but in
those days lee there was no real
strength gage
he was making him off the chart
sometimes you ate him and you saw the
devil
sometimes you couldn't feel your face
yeah sometimes you didn't see me that
sometimes you [ __ ] went out sometimes
you
ate them and nothing happened i hear
when they have but i used to go he used
to tell me if you come tuesday mornings
i'll hook you up
we do shove up you shove whatever edible
in your mouth no no no no i'd [ __ ] go
down open your mouth he would give me
one of each of whatever he baked
to try and take for free he's like just
take it so me the [ __ ] sabbath that i
am how would he savage and i would
always have a quarter to one
acupuncture
and that's the beginning of my
acupuncture and i would go in there dog
and i would get the
you're the most interesting man in the
world man [ __ ] that
man bro can you [ __ ] believe you're
the [ __ ] guy bro
he has had blow at early in the morning
and didn't get acupuncture no no i
wasn't getting blown and then
that morning no no no this is this right
now around this time maryland's been
dead nine years wow no way yeah whenever
rick raymond what's your birthday is i
met the manager oh six november three
it was oh it was november third or
whatever
she's been dead for nine years i haven't
done a line of coke for nine years i
stopped doing coke like the weekend in
maryland died and i was in jersey
i had my own hotel room with sea caucus
and i couldn't wait to go back there
because my buddy was getting eight balls
for sixty dollars right off the [ __ ]
boat
and he kept telling me when you come
back just call me when you get to the
hotel bring it right to the hotel
and i remember getting to the hotel and
i didn't feel right
and i said tonight i got to go to sleep
i just didn't you know when you didn't
get the flu and my gigs were saturday
i had a benefit early and then they show
up in my high school so i don't want to
[ __ ] fly six hours to be sick let me
just stand so at night i didn't do coke
he called me the next money goes i got
that eight ball for you i go all right
tonight i'll see you in north bergen
that's when i got the call about
maryland
i went did the cop show and then i went
to my high school show he showed up and
i go i can't do it man not tonight
and then was when that like they buried
her on tuesday
but that monday i had an interview for a
movie
in fact
the guy who gave me this movie
the guy who gave me this movie i just
told you three four days in north
hollywood he was that guy he had another
guy and another guy calling me in that
monday and say to me we want to offer
you this role in a different movie
but he goes we have to shoot this in 21
days he goes we have to finish this by
thanksgiving we're working three weeks
straight
we we love you we love the audition
everything about you we got one problem
manager let me tell you what this
[ __ ] said to me he goes you got
a reputation of liking the party
and if you take this movie you can't be
a minute late because
everybody's on the set on every time
it's one room
it was like an aaa meeting yeah
that cut drew me like i went home i go
listen and i went i'm in and he goes
don't even give me an answer i want you
to think about it and think if you could
even stay clean for the 21 [ __ ] days
and then call me in the morning and i go
[ __ ] it i went home i thought about it i
did a good bye bump
and i [ __ ] showed up the next morning
a blast to the past and you know what i
didn't do coke because you had to be on
the set from eight to eight
so eight o'clock was when i would get
the itchies
and start
going [ __ ] and crazy but i was so
tired from being on the set all day i
would just get home eat and go to bed i
got a bunch of valium and i would just
take valium and just pass the [ __ ] out
and by the time i got to like the 28th
day i said why do coke now i've been
clean and that's how i stay [ __ ]
clean in that movie that was it was all
inclusive with the cat dying
the goodbye bump but these [ __ ]
people gave me that movie
so that's [ __ ] amazing i get the nine
years
so what i was telling you before was i
saw scarface
and i went in to see if that old man was
still alive because when i was hanging
out with him he was in the process of
moving to woodland hills yeah the
[ __ ] home people community there was
a sag they got a nice house up there
they exercise they box they get the
mingle [ __ ] movies play up there they
got every movie ever made up there if
they want to bring it to their room but
it's like 8 000 a month so he was
telling me he might need money and [ __ ]
his pension wasn't gonna pay for it so i
never seen him again so yeah now that i
went on imdb and clicked on to the movie
i did with him to see if i could see if
he's still alive
and i couldn't find them and the next
day paul t mary who i haven't spoken to
since he was on the podcast over there a
year and a half ago called me out of the
blue and he goes hey i got this roll
check it out if you want to do it i said
jack mcgee
so i'm playing the cop with the dude
from the fighter the father
the irish dude
yeah dude
hey
you know it's not a lot of money i don't
give a [ __ ] i'm gonna shoot right by my
house i get to act for a few [ __ ]
days who's better than me nobody they
got [ __ ] catering service right you
got a breakfast made feel like a doctor
you got to wear somebody else's sneakers
but you're shooting a movie right how
happy are you now how are you i get
early in the morning philippe what do
you want breakfast burrito you want
cheese on it nah
like craft service man
there's something about it like when
you're a comedian like at first i didn't
really i didn't understand it
i didn't know when i got on the set it
was like putting the [ __ ] thief in a
in a candy store like i robbed us out of
baseball
and then bronx county was too much
security but haven't been going in for a
[ __ ] pilot on abc
okay and booking it and going a wardrobe
manager you have no idea how crazy uncle
joey was and going to wardrobe at abc
right there on warship boulevard and
when i get there the lady says to me do
me a favor go in that room and change
it was a small room filled with women's
dresses with tags on them
you have any of those dresses i robbed
to go i just clipped like [ __ ] 200 of
those things when i got there i had a
bag with like a pair of jeans in there
when i left the bag weighed like 80
[ __ ] pounds i went on
sunset boulevard to every secondhand
shop i made like eight thousand [ __ ]
dollars and [ __ ] like oh yeah yeah doug
please
on every one of those movies i didn't
really know what was going on i was like
a [ __ ] criminal on those [ __ ] sets
i didn't know what was going on he was
in character and then people started
teaching me now there's food over there
that's why the food
manager i did not [ __ ] know what was
going on in set
till i got a show on nbc
with sydney portier's daughter
john aston's kid
it was a bunch of sons and daughters
from other tv shows that moved in
together they were attorneys and i got a
reoccurring role on a tv show and the
first day i didn't even know it was hit
i didn't even know what hit your line is
hit your mark yeah i just stood there
like joey would you please hit your mark
and i'm like what are you talking about
joey you got to walk over here and stand
right there and i would just and they
were like getting agitated
but the director was so sweet he's like
can i talk to you for a second have you
ever done this i'm like i'm a stand-up
[ __ ] comic i don't know nothing
i went to the audition i told the lady i
didn't want the [ __ ] audition when i
walked into lisa block's office
it's a partner blocked something i
walked in and i go listen i'd rather not
read for it i'm not going to get this
it's for a [ __ ] mexican dude she goes
your shirt
she goes just shut your mouth and read i
go i'm not going to [ __ ] get this and
i got to go to new york to refer analyze
that you're [ __ ] with my [ __ ] and she
goes read it yeah i called you here for
a reason and i read it and the [ __ ]
[ __ ] gave me the role and it was three
i was pissed
i for you [ __ ] up my new york trip and
[ __ ] now i gotta put that [ __ ]
audition on tape like a dumb [ __ ]
but i got it and i went in there guys i
didn't know nothing i didn't know
nothing too man when i came in to shoot
the first episode of superstore i was
nervous man because i never shot
anything in my life for television and
where am i gonna stand really yeah have
my first sitcom ever
to be honest
so man i made friends with a cameraman
i made friends with a stand-in i had
because i had a standing this fat
[ __ ]
if i had a stand-in and i'm like am i
really a fan of this factor but now he
was fatter than me so after um the
stand-in was there um you know getting
all the light you know doing all the
blocking i asked him hey bro what is it
what'd they tell you what did they tell
you where to stand bro what the [ __ ]
what do you think you understand that
then he'll tell me stand right there
just stand right there man and then i
made i made the the cameraman laugh that
was the one that was facing me so he'll
tell me felipe i'm torn to the right i
could see your whole face now
it was fun man
it's very nice
when they don't have that dumb attitude
to them that's how i was blessed i
really was because i seen people who got
tortured on a set dog
it's [ __ ] embarrassing
and the people who do it should be shot
wrong you shouldn't treat a fellow
[ __ ] worker like that yeah but
ellie's one of those places that the guy
has like he from a movie and [ __ ]
they'll [ __ ] with you a little bit
i did that show and they were very nice
to me on nbc then the show got cancelled
which was good thank god nobody saw me
but then i booked this creepy show
called 18 wheels of justice on tnt
when you're on 18 wheels of justice yeah
way before when it was tnn
damn before spike
this is when it was tnn oh my god way
before spike that was one of my real i
had one i had to read in front of
producers and my hand was
and i was a pimp i played a pimp with
white hoes and [ __ ] and it was chicks
from play mansion and [ __ ] and i had to
drive to san diego and they gave me per
diem dog i held onto that per diem you
know that was going right up my [ __ ]
nose it was like 68 dollars i made it
all the way back from san diego with
eight [ __ ] dollars
i ate those dried chicken cutlets from
the [ __ ] set i took salad chocolate
bars i was a savage in those [ __ ]
bagels
oh my god i went on that set the
director dog taught me and i was going
to acting class 200 a month to vanity
chubby and that director just broke me
like a [ __ ] but in a great way
like he's like why are you doing this
how come you're not smacking her ass oh
she's a girl well that's what you're
supposed to do if you're a pimp oh smack
their ass and i'm gonna smack a [ __ ]
ass you know what i'm saying like he set
me loose like that was the first guy and
i kept in touch with him for about a
year or two i kept in touch with that
guy he come to the comedy store with a
[ __ ] hose he's probably a realtor now
then we just don't deport it
and then we did the departure with that
[ __ ] dude what's the hand piece nick
torturo that was one of those poor
rodriguez that was embarrassing
was late four hours oh my god that was
embarrassing you have to wake him up at
his house gotta jump
break into his house and wake him up
get some paul wake up paul hey
oh my god that was
that director was [ __ ] embarrassed it
was funny remember joe diaz was supposed
to have a mustard to the whole movie and
then he shaved his mustache
he shaved his mustache and hit more
scenes he showed up to the set with no
mustache they made him a mustache it was
a horrible mustache it kept falling
apart it was like um it was like um that
black tape
oh my god
why would he do that to him he was a
mexican cub with a with a cuban accent i
used to talk
what year was that 2007 2007. i was
clean then i was i don't think southern
eight yeah i wasn't snorting for that
movie you were blazing i was blazing
like three hands you gotta [ __ ] take
that monkey off your back yo was that
100 a day moving yes it was cold too it
was it was cold it was cloudy i don't
remember how the food was
but i remember paul being late i mean i
had scenes with you i was just happy for
you i remember that kid calling me going
dog you sent me a [ __ ] animal
he's the real deal he's going to be huge
his [ __ ] he loved you he said you
reminded him of his brother yeah so that
was good for me that i recommended you
knocked it out of the park and it
doesn't matter it's a hot all-day it was
fun man it was 6.95 or a thousand you
you know people get confused like this
movie i'm doing is 125. i don't give a
[ __ ]
man you know it's funny
there was a real legendary actor and we
were the david
david parada
you smoke weed with him he was a guy he
wasn't mean streets
he was like the porn man al pacino
not david pro
pray to provel dog richard oh [ __ ] hell
yeah bro i turned him off
he's like oh [ __ ] look at his life lisa
got lost i [ __ ] him up
you guys know who richie april is on the
surprise yeah richard felipe are doing
this [ __ ] movie he has to be a fresh
guy he has to eat
that's the first dude i dustly is richie
aprio from the movie set on the movie
set he went so crazy he went and got a
medical marijuana license for him and
his wife the next day yeah and that day
was chocolate bars he told us some good
stories
david provide was the real deal dawg you
say he trained um um he trained um eddie
murphy for um that movie um
trading places bro david profile watch
him on the sopranos he lived that season
up
he lit that season up he was only here
for a season
yeah he killed it bro killed him
i hated him i thought he was on for like
two seasons yeah he was a pain in the
[ __ ] ass he's a good actor huh look
he takes it out i just saw him in
something that they got a little heavier
but god bless those guys they're still
around he was so cool man about two
years ago no no no no about five years
ago you [ __ ] him up man no i gotta
call i did
oh my god
mean streets bro oh my god i tell you
when i did that
boiler maker movie
i did that movie with the dude from
and i forgot till the other night like
that's how [ __ ] up
my mind is like i forgot i did a movie
with the dude from
the movie with de niro with the gun in
vietnam desert
the deer hunter deer hunter john
whatever john savage
dog
there was a while where everybody john
savage i did like three movies with john
savage
he's a great guy
john savage isn't the [ __ ] he still
works
he's 70 something and he's still
shooting movies i am defeating him he's
still doing
it's like dean kane dean kane could be
here one week bulgaria canada chicago
and he'll do a movie with lee siyat and
then next week he'll do a movie with
dean with denzel washington
you know that's that's when you love it
that's when you really find the passion
for it they give you a nice salary i
mean he ain't hitting another part i
think he was disappeared
steven [ __ ] bower i have not seen him
on twitter [ __ ] taking pictures with
ukuleles
john savage was good in that movie that
movie is el salvador oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
the photographer in nicaragua
john savage is a real [ __ ] another
guy that you go on a set
and they talk to you like uh you're
[ __ ] dean martin
they don't have to talk to you
john savage really has no reason to
[ __ ] talk to you you know
one other guy taught me a lot
oh um
caddyshack
i'm blinking on his name right now
rodney dangerfield no the director but i
did dog that that hit harold rammus yes
how ramus [ __ ] me up that was
sensational auditioning for him
that [ __ ] me up but not as much as
being at the comedy store on a friday
and harry basel who i just called the
other day
still calling dawg harry basil came up
to me and he goes i'm going to have you
get an audition for rodney next week and
i thought it was like like in those days
you didn't know what people were telling
you i didn't tell nobody because i
didn't know if he was lying to me and
sure enough ten days later i got a call
you have to go in there and audition for
rodney but guess who i went in front of
the chick who gave me 18 wheels of
justice
so i already had a relationship with her
she had already booked me so she was
happy in front of rodney i went in there
and read for rodney
rodney goes bro you made me laugh he
goes the the role you read for i gave it
away
but call me in a few days i got
something for you
and a few days then i got a call from me
just to go to the set
what's it called that movie i don't even
know seven why is that one no no no no
it's [ __ ] horrific it's horrific but
rodney gave me eight days yeah in those
days well i was booking was one day one
day one day it was so [ __ ]
frustrating one day one day then i
busted two days on our list and i'm like
oh i'm getting there
and then i busted three days on
something and then they reduced it to a
one day co-star or some [ __ ] and i'm
like i'm never gonna [ __ ] get one
back up one day and analyze that i'm
like what the [ __ ] is wrong with my life
that's all it was was one day one day
for 10 projects in a row i did one
[ __ ] day
and i'm like god damn it i'm never gonna
bust out of the one [ __ ] day thing
you know i can't even keep my dental i
don't say no and also i got a call and
then i go in there and i go on the set
and then i go put a prisoner out for
that i go all right i want to put a
prisoner out for now and i walked around
and then also he put me and rodney
started going come here go on that scene
sit at that table time was it because
like i searched for but i can't find it
back to midnight
that's the that's the movie that's the
movie back to midnight and rodney is
like sitting that circle and also the
director's like uh he's got lines what's
his name
he turned around and goes uh jojo
2014.
so i was joking mr jojo but i was on
that set for [ __ ] eight days like
that's my first and it was like 460 a
day it wasn't scale but it was the one
under scale it was like 469 a day
doug would that check him in the mail
i ran to whitley hang on lightning
in hollywood they got the check cash in
place they take two points they'll cash
it 24 7. [ __ ] they're my type of people
they're my type of people i wouldn't
even tell them like i would go on the
sag thing when i get a residual if there
was a check there for a grand i'd tell
them the day before listen
you better have a grand in here because
i'm coming in tomorrow i'm gonna bust
but that was the first time felipe
and at the end of the day they i
wouldn't even be on the call she
i'm like where am i working tomorrow i
don't know go ask rodney i have to go
over his trail and knock on the door
hello come in what's up mr d
call me rodney
am i coming in tomorrow uh yeah come in
tomorrow we'll find something for you
and that's the first time i worked with
paul
so paul
is in parliament
paul was on his way down kind of sort of
and
a boy was [ __ ] smashing jor lopez so
george lopez was snapping
so there was a scene where the prisoners
are gonna have a dance
okay
and they really got real strippers
like i had that girl's number for like a
year
because she gave me a number she's like
i do parties i don't take it in the ass
i'm like oh it's nice to meet you you
know what i'm saying like
like i've been dancing with you you've
been breathing on my neck
for the last hour here i thought you
were an extra and that's what she
started telling me oh well hookers and
strippers here
they wanted this because they wanted a
real feel
for the [ __ ] party they didn't want
polished up girls this just breathing on
my thing drinking my [ __ ] water
you know what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
now you gotta drop a bomb on me now you
got i don't know what you got i gotta go
and take two showers
but they really did but there was a
scene where
uh
rodney and and at this point guys rodney
was old
like he didn't know his lines like they
had a guy with cue cards a little bit
before his brain surgery and then well
for me in my world felipe i didn't
everybody was going to montreal i wasn't
going to montreal hell no everybody was
at gersch i wasn't that girish
everybody got invited to parties i
wasn't going to invite it to dick i was
at the comedy store
so when i got to the woods rodney yeah i
was like you could all suck my dick
that [ __ ] hand picked me from
the choir you know what i'm saying
i'm like what was the driver for [ __ ]
uh the little casey's he's the one that
had the jaguar that he kept talking in
the jaguar that guy always said i picked
him from the choir
he picked me from the choir right there
he picked me from the [ __ ] store dog
you know what i'm saying i would go in
there he'd be in a robe smoking a joint
and i go mr d it might come out it's
rodney yeah come in tomorrow and i just
go in there and do one scene but this
particular scene and then when they
would go cut
paul rodriguez would take the microphone
start banging on him and start doing
right yeah how are you doing the funny
thing and he came hold on
he said running he kept doing it and
doing it and doing it
and only some of the extras
and the camera people were laughing the
rest of the people in the room that knew
rodney knew not to laugh like i was
online because i didn't think it was
[ __ ] funny you did it one time it's
great now let's let it go let it go but
every time they'd say cuddy go all right
cut you heard rodney okay
and one time rodney
and he goes paul before you say
something
so help me god say one more [ __ ] word
i'll fire you and replace you with
george lopez
film end of game and the story you
didn't hear one word from paul rodriguez
the rest of the [ __ ] shoot
boy loco and that was it
that was it but that was a great
experience i remember getting the check
was like 3 600 hours
it was like the most i had seen in
[ __ ] 10 years
check cash was happy oh check cash was
happy and [ __ ] dog what are you crazy
those are the days of jacob told us
we're doing this in class
along with a [ __ ] the family of cats
stop touching the microphone see lee fix
his microphone pilot the bombardier how
you feeling lee you ready for the last
mushroom tip of death they took it to
the left 300 bucks they took you to the
back to give you a stack of money
that's crazy i used to live in that
[ __ ] check man for a while man
because child support was going after
everything they had everything man lisa
and the manager and i we had to go early
my flight was at eight
at nine but i got there early to um the
check cashing place over there in south
central by the airport to just catch my
check bro
and then they charged me right like a
900 dollar check from the laugh factory
of for a whole month of gigs there
but i was happy man
thank god for nick cashing place dog
when they cash your check you don't give
a [ __ ] you don't give a [ __ ]
i don't give a [ __ ]
it's all right as long as you're cashing
the check though i used to do some
creepy [ __ ]
so i knew i couldn't get away with dick
i wouldn't even try to [ __ ] with don't
check cash and people
because it was my home they they were
open 24 hours whitley oh that means if
you went to the comedy store and there
was a check for 32.50
i'm getting the 20 i'm getting the 20.
you know what i'm saying i just got to
go to willy i'll be right back hold on
to that 20 for uncle joey
and it was 32.50 so they give you like
29. who gives a [ __ ] i got nine for
breakfast i'll figure it out tomorrow
you know what's that ready to go ready
to [ __ ] go it's amazing that check
cash i got into that check cashing place
in 1997
and i stayed going there to 2000 and
[ __ ] eight problem
would you do it for all your checks only
when you really needed everything i had
everybody looking for me at one point
they were all looking forward to the gas
bill there oh my god it was terribly
terrible
i never got the credit card the atm card
from there not a waste of your time yes
but i would oh my god you know when you
when my
my wife filed a judgment on me
probably like in 97
thank god it never got to comedy clubs
like the only time a comedy club ever
got a call was in the beginning manager
i would go to a comedy club and they go
this number this dude called for you
and i pick up the phone and they'd be
american express
like how did you know i was here why
were you snuck around and we know you
were beginning comic and [ __ ] they
started calling me at [ __ ] lounges
then like open mics at the broker you
know how embarrassing that [ __ ] is
then they called comedy works when then
on a tuesday night my heart almost
[ __ ] stopped
my heart almost stopped they came up to
me they go the guy's been on hold for 15
minutes
that's [ __ ] embarrassing man in 1999
i went with ruben quintana and luke
torres to do a show at mit
or the college gig the day after
thanksgiving on a friday
it was a good night man
we didn't know that rich that ruby
quintana ordered a lot of child support
to his wife
child support got his check at mit that
night and we didn't get paid
i was supposed to get paid six hundred
dollars rubric and tanner was the kid
that met the chick with the eight kids
yes and then he moved away
no more
christian comedy right i called him one
time and said a bunch of [ __ ] on his
answering machine he called me back dog
this is a christian house
what are you talking about i just saw
you eating something
i just seen you [ __ ] eating some
dirty chick at a bar in albuquerque rudy
used to have a bar called
fleas no bugsies bugsies
on tuesday nights wednesday nights
in a flight i had to fly the southwest
flight and the hotel was [ __ ] up but
that hotel today is like very chic with
a golf course on yeah they got showers
with blue [ __ ] heads on it no no
shower curtain all fancy and [ __ ] you
went with you went with gabriel his
first gay guy
when he got laid
when he got laid that night and then
remember classic knights was i went with
what's his name
the old man
the omaha larry omaha and i saw larry
omaha
[ __ ] hit me if there was 18 women in
the room
larry omaha hit on all 18 of them and
the guy that was thinking of being a
transgender
you know what i'm saying
wow
i saw him ask everybody to dance and i
remember sitting there like doing a
couple lines of coke
because big alex that place yeah that
place as soon as you walked in they put
a package in your hand yes weed whatever
you wanted weed coke whatever the [ __ ]
hookers
and the
hotel was disgusting disgusting bro
you've seen those dogs that have hair
that's been bit off that's how the
carpet look
disgusting i went back there the maid
stole my towels maybe i went back there
to do a gig at that what laps
laughs and
albuquerque is that albuquerque with
hood
with no hood wasn't there this is an
independent night some kid hiring me to
go down there tuesday and wednesday
after the longest yard we got like 92
people in two nights we died
he had to give me like a light envelope
i didn't give a [ __ ] i was just happy to
go it was like but the hotel he put me
in was that same hotel
and it was [ __ ] beautiful now yeah it
was [ __ ] beautiful it's amazing what
a couple years dudes
the crack hotels have disappeared
that's it that's all you got to tell me
felipe and bring you all the way up this
[ __ ] hill off seattle how was seattle
oh amazing man what's the name of the
club um parlor live we were there last
week rodrigo and i and toby hicks
it's funny man we were um we're walking
around our city and rodriguez rolling up
a joint in front of starbucks you know
trying to keep ignito rolling it up
and then there's this crazy white dude
standing next to us giggling you know we
don't know who the [ __ ] he is but i
thought he was a narc they were looking
at rodrigo um light up his roll up the
joint
and then he looks at me he goes oh man
don't don't worry about me man i just
have a machete in my bag right now and
then look he had a [ __ ] machete he
goes i'm just waiting for somebody man
they're going to buy the machete they
had it on craigslist seattle yeah
bellevue and i'm thinking man he
probably he probably i'll see you
tomorrow i saw when i looked at him i
said man are you going to chop everybody
up right now man cause you do after i
leave
he was just standing behind us all
creepy without machete man we're gonna
talk about creepy dog i went to downtown
l.a tonight oh my god holy [ __ ] it's
like the one stream we lost i had to go
to eddie bravo's uh jiu jitsu tournament
by the way it was [ __ ] beautiful at
the orpheum nice
gary tonan already [ __ ] had a heel
hook
i watched three or four matches and i
had to come back to do the podcast
but before you walk into the
orpheum no matter where you park whether
you park next to orpheum or you park
down the corner from the office you
don't lose
there's a burrito shack or something
down the corner i got two carnita tacos
like you ever get two tacos walk to the
car and it's like a mile away yeah and
you're like i should have got 22 tacos
all the time by the time you get to the
car you like those [ __ ]
that pork was a money jack but i'm like
[ __ ] i'm already across the lot that
means i gotta walk back my hands are
greasy so this time i made a mental note
i'm going to park next to that taco
place
but i got there and i parked next to the
orpheum and on the way
lee pizza
and i remember last time somebody got a
slice and said that pizza was off the
chain it's been there for 2000 years
and they put like exotics up on pizza
it's like uh super sat on [ __ ] goblin
hollow cheese and [ __ ] where's this at
right on eighth and broadway right next
to the [ __ ] orpheum theater and as i
was walking and i smelt like oh well i
gotta take a chance dog at the window
two black dudes came up to me one on
each side dog i used to be a dancer in
harlem the other guy told me he was in
the navy and shot some [ __ ] governor
and i'm like all right so what do you
want from me can you this something a
dollar something i gave the one guy
changed that's a mistake because now
they all [ __ ] charge you so i started
giving them all change and dollar bills
and they still wouldn't leave me alone
then they come back for a second to
listen i gotta tell you a story listen i
gave you a dollar so i didn't have to
hear a [ __ ] story all right
they're everywhere down there
it's like that show that [ __ ] people
watch what is it that were dead people
walking around walking
dead downtown
noma every 20 [ __ ] feet while i'm
standing eating a pizza lady walks to me
with as much legal clothing as she had
to wear she was completely [ __ ] bald
not a tooth in her [ __ ] mouth and she
was walking past me like she was
brigitte bardot
they call her moonraker i'm like what
[ __ ] planet are you on but i can't
say nothing who am i
you know there was two dudes across the
street doing something they were doing
something
i just looked and kept [ __ ] walking
instead of my business you know me i
ain't got you know they weren't hitting
somebody
or raping somebody but they were doing
something like smoking heroin they were
doing something creepy it was [ __ ]
seven o'clock at night guy
the cool thing is to move down there now
would you ever move down there yeah yeah
look at me i'm looking for the map right
now i'm gonna move down there that's the
first place that's going to fall apart
when the earthquake [ __ ] comes right
under the one time
i used to live over there yeah right by
the way i used to live on first and
maine yeah you're [ __ ] crazy that's
the hip thing why don't you move down
there you and mama down there
we're down the block from the staples
center
i'm not going down there
yes you are they're gonna have a new
building the festo's tower and [ __ ]
i'm not fast
[ __ ] guy moving asbestos like i'm
gonna move downtown because it's [ __ ]
him i know two people moved downtown and
then they moved the [ __ ] out and never
came back downtown is on your way out
downtown is where you move when you're
like you know what i'm thinking i'm
going to move downtown and all of a
sudden it becomes [ __ ] real down
there it has to every time i go to down
you know how many times i like going
downtown
never
never i don't i haven't gone to the last
two ebis not out of disrespect number
one i always get lost i don't know what
temple is i don't know what grand is the
one way it takes one yeah party
next thing you know i'm in pasadena you
know
yeah it's a [ __ ] nightmare
north how do i end up in the one [ __ ]
10 north
yeah so it just pisses me the [ __ ] off
so i just avoid downtown
crunch my wife used to work at the
disney center i used to have to bring it
down and bring [ __ ] down there it was a
four-hour adventure
and every time you get on the 101 north
no matter what time it is it's bumping
the [ __ ] bumper today i ain't going
to complain it was very easy to get down
there yeah man against the [ __ ]
there's homeless everywhere they're
everywhere in downtown at the comedy
club we're at in salt lake city man
there's a lot of homeless people there
that's a great club by the way yeah well
next year i'm excited shout out to keith
tubbs keith stubbs
right
i think so i don't know when i just they
put you next to the the old club they
used to put you next to olive garden
yeah and it's the business west valley
garden in the country number one olive
garden in the country white people got
mixed samoans i can't wait i can't wait
to get that cavatelli
whatever the [ __ ] they call it lisa how
you feeling you ready to kill these
mushrooms
it's time dog listen they're gonna leave
i'm gonna put on black salmon we're
gonna reminisce about the old days when
you want to be a vampire whoever
have a tv deal you do i heard that you
and [ __ ] awesome me and dustin ibarra
dustin borrows one of you know lee and i
had this conversation but lee says he
sees him all the time
as long as dustin had borrowed his
eyeballs and popping out of his head
he'll always have a job in hollywood
what i'm saying i look at him and i
think young frankenstein remake in 10
years gene wilde is dead i don't feel so
good myself you give him a different
haircut that's [ __ ] he's going to get
he's going to get the guy's role what's
his guy marty feldman i'm already
following him he's going to get marty
feldman's role there's no he's going to
lock it up
lock it up they're going to shave him a
certain way his eyes are going to move
and [ __ ]
what do you think you're dealing with
that's a tremendous [ __ ] casper i
congratulate you with that
you've worked very hard for a lot of
people don't know that you know for
years that we you know these
[ __ ] think he's just doing this
[ __ ] like youtube yeah they don't know
me and years that we
jesus christ all those tuesdays and
wednesdays and
san diego leonard and vice
no he never liked me
he never liked i went up there and
caused [ __ ] damage one time i went up
there and tormented the limit and then i
knew he didn't like me so what did i do
is my weekly routine i harassed him i
put him lee
when they don't like it they're not
going to buy
now you use them as practice
if they're not going to buy you might as
well put them on your rotation to warm
up who am i going to call them bother
today
i used to have a list
you got to have a little list of who
you're gonna call and bother
and
you know it's a warm-up you just call
them up and they're not gonna buy you
already know they bought it the piano
you were gonna sell them they bought
somewhere else but you know what you
want to warm up isn't that kind of like
burning a bird is that like you're
bothering the [ __ ] out of these poor
people who gives a [ __ ] next time
they'll plan ahead
the ship's not safe
for what you're worth
you watch the first scene in rocky it's
one of the strongest scenes of all time
he goes on the dock and he chases the
guy that's how it opens up people don't
remember he chases a dude he catches him
with a two by four yeah he doesn't have
the money
he takes his [ __ ] jacket
and he's supposed to break his hand but
he doesn't break his fingers but on the
way out he goes i'll give you don't you
want to hurt me he's going to know you
didn't break my hand
and he goes i'll catch you next time and
he goes but you should have planned that
that's a he's got him he's looking at
him and the [ __ ] away still alone goes
you should have planned ahead
watch rocky in the beginning and that's
why you know you should have planned the
head now you want to come with this
[ __ ] story
i uh i went to speaking of records and
moving movies all this stuff i went to
uh amoeba this weekend it was great
it was then tell them how you [ __ ] up
the night oh my god you know i love this
kid but he is the kiss of death when it
comes to restaurants when i was 418
pounds i was eating quality philippi
we're not [ __ ] killing telling the
truth there's no fast food in our future
no
okay i've been trying to guide this guy
but you don't give a [ __ ]
once his girlfriend gets them on fridays
or saturdays how are you the [ __ ] if
there's a cat on the stick
and she sells two of them it's to him
and his girlfriend you know what i'm
saying
like that's the luck [ __ ] those guys he
poisoned his leg scooters he poisoned
his father she got boys
he got poisoned at a sushi place i
didn't get poisoned poisoned me with the
edible yeah he blames on me no it wasn't
the sushi it's the wholesale solution
and dude it wasn't my fault yes you
wanted there's like eight pieces of 50
cents what do you think is going to
happen to you you're going to die yeah
you wanted that happy happy happy hour
like nine to 10. we're at right before
right here like in [ __ ] some dark
street you know what i'm saying some
streets
yeah that dark mall where nobody goes
into they have foot massages and a
liquor store they have a bank of america
yeah no no no it's got nothing to do
with the [ __ ] sushi place it's like
happy he went in there like a 10 to 10.
either lee eats it or they're gonna give
it to the cat
or the mouse behind the thing lee went
in there oh my god he's trying to blame
it on the same edibles that i ate no
yeah because you've been doing them for
a long time no no don't blame me you're
trying to say they were bad edibles they
were they're not bad edible they were
super strong then he tells me what are
you doing tonight league of legends
i go perfect you get some posters for
your room and [ __ ] i go leave you know i
go lee you know what and you're in a
perfect photo yeah he's got posters you
know like he's got the godfather on his
wall he was on he's on cooking blue
apron the other day which i love him
he's got pictures of [ __ ] you know
like the movies he grew up i was like 23
when i moved out here he's got [ __ ]
what is that [ __ ] he's got orange is the
new purple no i don't
the worst case scenario if you bail out
i mean i know he's a little [ __ ] up
and he eats stars and he eats edibles i
can go to jack in the box
but 55 40 yards from there you got stout
one of the best burgers you could eat
hollywood it's a little pricey but
you're out with your girlfriend lift the
rock and if she doesn't want a hamburger
walk 30 yards and you go to the old
houstons and they have some sort of
barbecue that [ __ ] all like he likes
anything and then or you go 10 more
yards and go to a pizza that him and i
go to constantly and he loves it he's
two slices he only eats one but on the
way home you can see him he's mad at
himself on the 101.
he knows he's like i could've had a
piece of a pizza and one tonight so i
could watch cheers
yeah but you don't let me take it home
i'm gonna have three i'll let you do
what the [ __ ] you want you know me i
said get two i got two slices yeah but
then if i get two slices and i try to
take one home i can't take it home
anyways three of them at one two one
yeah one in the car one two three no
it's the end of the [ __ ] world so
next time so what do you think this
[ __ ] momo does
he's in the center of good food down
there he's going to the york light he
tells me go ahead yeah we were going to
go to the ark lab but the movie times
didn't work out
but
we've never been to roscoe's i've it's
it's just waffles yeah
so he goes instead of going to the one
down in pico the hood
he went to the tourist one do i look
like i belong in the hood next to the
palladium right if you're gonna [ __ ]
walk on ice you might as well dance lee
you went and it's next to a place i
can't believe you didn't get the [ __ ]
thai place next door did you have to
wait no no no no we didn't have to wait
but it was terrible there was actually a
very nice uh one of the servers was a
listener and it was but uh the food was
the food was just it came out in like
two minutes which is you know we we
looked at each other and we're like this
is not good
and even on even on
order
just as normal did you go on yelp
afterwards chicken and waffles yeah
yep no i went on yelp just to see
what the reviews were and the reviews
are four stars so they're gone so there
you go see what the [ __ ] you don't i
don't ever want you to read a [ __ ]
review again
retards go home and report about [ __ ]
restaurants they're complaining about
everything yeah if you're gonna read
that [ __ ] you might as well shoot
yourself the way to have bad breath
now the the surface was actually the
best thing to be honest but
the [ __ ] the food was just terrible
i haven't done it every time i've gone i
bought to the one on pico and i gotta
tell you i never had waffles and [ __ ]
chicken in my life it's not like i'm
running down there i can't eat a lot of
maple syrup but that [ __ ] chicken
with the waffle a little maple syrup
hits the chicken a little red hot sauce
i don't like it dreaded in the [ __ ]
maple syrup now you're getting out of
control yeah but just when i taste one
of the corners you put some frank's hot
sauce on that [ __ ]
and you bite into that chicken it
squirts a little bit oh yeah it burns
you i get mine smothered and covered
listen i've had vegan
i had vegan chicken and waffles pretty
good too listen i don't want to hear
about that topping delicious i'm having
a good night tonight
happy holidays in san jose do not listen
again do not listen do not listen vegan
no vegan nothing here we all [ __ ]
meat eaters all right so please
last time you're insulting people league
out
it was hangover he got insulted hungover
can't be doing that [ __ ] uh i have poo
food poisoning in the same city twice
washington dc adam chipotle
you went back again yeah sure why are
you eating that [ __ ] pork man
pork broth i can't believe that mexican
people would walk into a chipotle or if
i haven't brought but i love taco bell
man but sharks oh dog nice [ __ ] taco
with the sauce i'm talking about man
sorry it was burrito supreme it's like a
[ __ ] it's that night at two in
the morning oh you wake up and your
[ __ ] opens up the manager right here
400 400 calories per burrito oh sh
200 calories
oh my god that [ __ ] burrito so i
haven't had one in 15 [ __ ] years i
have one the last time i stopped tonight
you know because what happens is you you
test the waters one night you're a
little stoned you're driving home you're
by yourself you're like nobody will know
i'll put the skies on
yeah i'm saying there's only three
people in the line you go in there you
get like a diet pepsi and you let me
just [ __ ] try what's going on and you
get yourself like a burrito supreme and
on the way home it's not bad not about
three months later you're like [ __ ]
nobody's gonna know
it's 11 15. ain't nobody in there
there's four people online but they
always advertise something that new
thing with the baby where the guy dips
the [ __ ]
stick in there so now you're really high
because only if you're really high when
you get that [ __ ] stick with that
chicken yeah tell me i want to see the
chicken i want to see the process you
know what they do
they get this chicken that's been
tortured and beat and cages cake views
which some abused chicken ain't bad have
you ever had not a have you ever had
abused chicken it ain't that bad he's
been kicked
like it's better you know that's abused
natural chicken chicken had low
self-esteem chickens have been getting
chased for 10 2000 [ __ ] years
now you want to give me a chicken and
never got an arrow shot at it you know
what i'm saying
the [ __ ]
free range what the [ __ ] is wrong with
people
what are we talking about anyway i like
my chicken from foster home taco bell
like i was telling lee lee likes those
dumplings from koreatown let me tell you
what a dumpling in koreatown is [ __ ]
johnny ying takes the chicken chops his
[ __ ] head off right now he's got a
chicken with a stem right
he takes it he debones that chicken he
takes all the white meat off he puts in
the pile now he takes that chicken and
that head with that eyeball he takes
that and out of that [ __ ] bony mess
that still has a little thing
puts in this [ __ ] machine and he
pushes it down and he doesn't give you
the nice white meat he gives you that
brown [ __ ] meat that like the kidneys
and all that and he puts it all in there
with feathers and [ __ ]
spiders and eyeballs and he crunches
that up and then johnny ying takes that
plate he rubs it like this he puts in
the [ __ ] rice paper and he calls it a
dumpling you go in there eat it you [ __ ]
blood for two weeks and you can't figure
out what's going on with your [ __ ]
life you had a hemorrhoid
no i've never had hemorrhoids yes he has
no i have not have any look at him he's
another
look at the size of this [ __ ] guy i
had a hemorrhoid i had like 10 of them
over [ __ ] 280 you're gonna get
hemorrhoids yeah because you eat your
ass isn't prepared for that [ __ ] there's
an old cuban saying
all right
you know look at him he don't have
[ __ ] problems or anything he just
goes to the bathroom and shits out the
kelp what do you think look at him he
goes to the bathroom he cries himself in
there legs are falling out here he lives
here
dog he was eating gluten there's a place
around the corner from the ymca it's
known for listening
they got shot
they got shut down
what do you think he buys tacos that's
elizabeth
iguanas
you know lee just has bad luck with food
yeah that's why we got him a [ __ ]
little stomach we got him uh we got him
uh where did we get you later the lap
band a [ __ ] thing no no we didn't get
on my lap
he lost 100 pounds on his own we got him
a big day
yeah that i'm doing great in the
bathroom i don't know what you're
talking about
listen lee cleaned up all night they
just don't come out you only eat
anything then when was the last time you
had a salad
the salad you yelled at me about the
caesar salad yeah because no because you
eat salads at the wrong places he goes
to a neighborhood bar and gets a caesar
sound and he's like you can't mess up a
caesar salad yeah bro a neighborhood
plantation right they put [ __ ] uh
they put [ __ ] blue they put uh ranch
and instead of caesar you don't know
don't tell me though i know what the
branch tastes like when was the last
time you had a salad tell me the truth i
just told you
a year ago
when they let them they tossed it
was the last time you had a salad
look enough
a hamburger
anything [ __ ] that'll [ __ ] him up he
loves all that [ __ ] but he won't just
eat it at mama he wants it dipped in
honey or something you gotta eat right
like rodrigo man eating escargot on the
road
hell yeah you like escargots
i bought blue cheese i'm making wings
the next day he tells me he made
barbecue wings i go so what did you do
with the blue cheese i dipped it in
there listen i know 2 000 people nobody
dips barbecue [ __ ]
wings and blue chips yes they do well
in the line they got a [ __ ] they got
lighter
so i got to deal with this [ __ ] now you
know this is johnny football
if there's a bad that's what you should
do lee give a bad restaurant review any
restaurant you go to
just give a review on it do a thing
online
you must have put them
yes you did right at the right at the
blackjack table when you walked away
that's when you put the mulligan you put
the malouk on yourself you take chances
eating those dumplings
and you eat at these [ __ ] creepy
places you've gone to places i'm taking
you no no i do not eat it
if i smell curry i don't even park the
car
you know me i smell curry i don't even
[ __ ] i love curry dog i had some
people from gower studio that wanted to
meet me one day and they had decided on
something and also at the last minute
they go we're at the thai place hangar
next to
roscoe's chicken
and i had to tell him i go listen i
can't even walk in there because curry
after 10 minutes i gotta go
i start my aqua
i start gagging at the high school you
don't like it no i don't like it around
me i don't like what it smells like none
of that [ __ ]
so i get sick all that [ __ ] food for
that throwing up huh a couple of years
ago dog in 84 i was painting bathtubs
imagine this pool with the spray gun
oh dog
in 84 i was dating this girl technical
and she couldn't dump me because i
borrowed money from her father
and i had to pay him back by spraying
tubs
she wanted to break up with me [ __ ] her
old boyfriend but [ __ ] no she was
tighter than [ __ ] she knew if i broke up
with her she had to cover the 400.
so she had to keep [ __ ] doing what
i'm doing you understand me you know me
dog i'm a psychological i'm like [ __ ]
uh the people who eats dudes you're the
man with a plan hannibal that's right
and i used to get up on i used to do it
with him tuesdays thursdays and saturday
mornings
the guys used to pay me a lot of loot
he got out of prison
he got out of prison and went to a
convention
that in those days if you want probation
you were required to go
and he got a small business loan
to buy into this thing called permissor
and what it was it was your own
neighborhood so you got your own turf
so let's say you got the valley he got
the valley before nobody knew so instead
of buying a new tub
he would come over for 400
and resurface your [ __ ] tub
he had to wear a gas mask and all i had
to do was open beers for him
and give him beers that's all i did
though
we had to stop at the liquor store i'd
get a cooler put 12
12 pack of budweiser cans filled with
ice
and then we go to the gigs i taped the
job off i cleaned the tub
i put that acid on it i put the mask on
and then i'd scrub the acid off and then
i'd dry the [ __ ] tub down we'd drink
a beer or two i'd go outside and smoke a
joint
and then i come back and it'd be all
taped off and he would go go do what you
do
and i would [ __ ] he would spray the
[ __ ] tub and then we would wait an
hour put all this [ __ ] back in the car
and then we would take the paper off
voila the tub was done
and that was my hook for a while that's
what i did and one saturday one friday
night i went and did like 22 8 balls out
of wedding and i had to meet him at
eight in the [ __ ] morning
and we went to the nicest people's
houses they were american they were
those hindus
the patel's nicest people in the world
he got a contract to do all the tubs in
that [ __ ] place and i remember going
with him like at 7 30 in the morning
when that coke is still in your nose
and you're burping that [ __ ] long
island iced tea and [ __ ] i was young
though
i was young
i was drinking iced teas all night your
heads pounding and i walked into this
beautiful hindus house
and as i'm spraying the [ __ ] as i'm
cleaning the tub i could smell the curry
i'm starting to get dizzy
i'm starting to get dizzy i go outside
to get air i come to my senses i stick
my finger down my throat i puke
i go back in these beautiful people's
homes they offer me water they know i'm
not feeling well and then they came back
with this [ __ ] hindu mush
and they go taste this and i'm one of
those dudes manager that i listen don't
bother me over the curry it was
something horrible
horrible
cubans make tamales
yeah it's pretty [ __ ] good
it's a tamale soup
the texture is very rich and it takes a
while it's one of those tastes to
acquire
not everybody likes tamales as well my
mom used to make it with little pieces
of lobster meat
and then you put picante on it but it's
you got to eat it really hot because
it's not it hardens into a [ __ ]
tamale you know what i'm saying that's
why so you got to eat this tamale soup
away it's got to be boiling it's [ __ ]
hot it's burning so your mom pours it
then you gotta pour the hot sauce on
this [ __ ] there's little pieces
of lobster it's alive and then you gotta
take an ice cube and put it in the
middle and then you really dope that
[ __ ]
gumbo oh my god it had the same texture
i only tasted it because it had the
texture of tamale and caswella i it was
white it wasn't that orange texture that
tamale has champagne it was a white text
and i tasted it and it had that curry in
it
and i spit it right out in front of
these poor people you know me i got no
class
i couldn't get it i couldn't even get
the napkin it came out with the vodka
and the tonics and the blow and the cut
the aluminum foil and the [ __ ] days
[ __ ] through a poison i puked in
front of these poor [ __ ] indian
people burned their faces and i knew
ever since then 1984 i knew don't invite
me to a curry joint
all right since 1984 i don't hang out
with curry people
you understand milly i don't know what
they eat i don't know who i don't know
who eats curry anymore i do i don't have
the police don't coconut mind me because
you're gonna upset me i'm having a good
time because i'm always happy to see you
i don't want to open up the vegan door
please don't upset me please
if not you're gonna start talking about
you your wife made flan i can't have
that
i love more than two chicken molly i
can't have that i almost reported to you
you know i'm not a rat i almost reported
to you to the cuban embassy last time
you put those fake tofu bananas up there
hurt me
deep in my [ __ ] soul manager you know
what i'm saying i almost reported you to
the cuban embassy that's right they
would have thrown you in jail
they would have pulled you to cuba
they would have taken you back to cuba
and i'm not there to help you i told you
don't [ __ ] with you before leave it
alone
if you're not gonna eat the beef leave
it alone please don't insult me
what's up buddy always a pleasure seeing
you oh hell yeah likewise
bro lee you're gonna eat that mushroom
or you're gonna [ __ ] sit there
and what are you gonna do what the [ __ ]
is going on that [ __ ] lady every
weekly you want to eat this mushroom or
what at least
more yeah sure what do you got left two
caps or one cap you don't mean though
we're going deep inside i'll take a
little cap that other one didn't like
just made the [ __ ] uh
the uh
made that [ __ ] more vivid the colors and
the lighting
80 of the reason i do this podcast
i really enjoy doing it i have a great
time doing it but i got to be honest
with you guys it's my two days of
hanging out with this poor bastard
because i got all the respect in the
world for lisa at lee sayak came from a
complete different world where i came
from
and he's gone through hell he caught the
vapors i've never beat him up i've never
kicked him in the stomach and disrespect
them but i've given them [ __ ] that can
kill a mule don't blame me for that
[ __ ] sushi [ __ ] it wasn't the
soup she got food poisoning no i did not
you know i give credit when credit is
due my edibles are always solid nobody's
ever gotten sick you gotta wash your
hands when you eat sushi you know
i always never said the edibles were bad
i'm just i've done it a couple of times
so you get over high what do you have a
sensitive stomach nobody no i have a i
have a sense of
500 milligrams for the first time
no you eat that one i got another one
for me i'm gonna eat a
cat with lee where is it lee
we got more reefer here we got
everything it's so we got everything
here
yellow bro
huh
i don't know about you lee you gotta go
and then eat that [ __ ] shroom and
everything's gonna be [ __ ] better you
know what i'm saying enough enough we're
going deep tonight look at this oh [ __ ]
deep deep into the murkish waters give
that to lee right there that's his
little party right there oh yeah god
damn oh yeah
wow that's you that's literally that's
the last of it lee i won't even ask you
don't do yours
no no no no no it's sunday night
you got a complete thought you want a
bigger piece no i need a small no just
for felipe that's it that's still i just
ate the last big piece
that's it it lasts off that's it you eat
that there's no more mushrooms till new
year's
then and we do this acid i got acid here
too
but we'll save that for vegan acid no
it's
it's not vegan acid the paper has beef
juice on it and [ __ ]
lee we're going deep in the murky waters
it's over you're breaking your own
record what's the problem here you're
breathing heavy you're making noises
i'm high it's the
that's what it's all about that's it
you always tell me you want to see the
devil i never say that no you don't want
to see me that
you want to [ __ ] see me right now
guys
got to get a little jeff on this show
had him on here huh no because he you
know it's he lives like [ __ ] ontario
don't he
he lives deep in the [ __ ] basement
yeah lee what are you doing don't make
money you're breaking it in half you're
doping you think you're magician i'm
trying to break who the [ __ ] do you
think you're dealing with eat the
[ __ ] thing lee and salt chew it man
you're insulting me you you know you're
insulting me and so this whole mushroom
society you're trying to fake the [ __ ]
and breaking and having salted sushi
this is unicef like you're breaking over
the pieces like there's eight kids
waiting for a piece of mushroom inhale
that [ __ ] thing be a marine
[ __ ] you represent the hebrews do
it for johnny man
[ __ ] johnny do it for the [ __ ] israel
army that's what you represent the
yakuza from israel japan
what are you thinking about what are you
huffing and puffing [ __ ] helmet on it
dude so what that's what you need in
your life you need help
you're in training this is what you get
for [ __ ] around all weekend
i had stars i went to my brussels
chicken and waffles brussels i'm over
here eating [ __ ] mushrooms by myself
you're the captain kirkland center
you're the co-captain of this enterprise
you can't let me go into this journey
who am i gonna call at two in the
morning and harass them
don't be don't be doing the puerto rican
switch check his fingers and [ __ ]
even chew it uh
you need some orange juice it's not
gonna happen you don't need no i guess
oh i got some great flavor oh yeah let
me give you some lift water this got
bubbles in it so good he forgot how to
chew oh no
he plays with it he [ __ ] sits there
it's covered in [ __ ]
i don't know what you're talking about
they're not in [ __ ] yes they are my
buddy cleaned them
infest relax here give them an apple
drink
they'll go down nice with the apple jack
you gonna say i'm not going to talk
about anything oh my god please you
gotta finish it that's bad luck and [ __ ]
no yes it is you can they'll put a curse
on you from the [ __ ] indians
you can't eat a little piece leave that
that's okay you puked before big [ __ ]
deal
it's sunday night [ __ ]
it's good to see you felipe always a
pleasure to see you man always a
pleasure to see rodrigo we go back way
back when we took the [ __ ] acting
class and the gay dude and [ __ ] yeah
theater in your backyard and cisco
brought his son
was there too huh the kiss of death
rick robles we're all smoking
i left rick ramos a message today
i haven't spoken to rick ramos in two
years probably whoa
it's been a while last time i've seen it
was at the laugh give us a rick romwe
bro
eat that mushroom
you gotta eat half of it at least i ate
the [ __ ] four things i'm over here
giggling by myself look at my eyeballs
no you're not you're over there having
entire nights
put the mushroom in your night drink the
apple water over here looking like pablo
escobar you don't mean dog we'll stay on
the air till you eat that mushroom so
the quicker you would just throw it into
your throat and down it with the apple
drink
we'll all be gigging we'll put some pink
floyd on everybody goes well he eats
that can i mention my shows this week
sure talk about your show tell them
about it for the rest of the day i'll be
at the edison edison improv this week
thursday through sunday this week in
dallas
also um watch me on the superstore on
thursday at 8 pm on nbc check out my
what's up food podcast with rodrigo
torres and
my wife and i have a podcast enchilada
casserole we talk about birth
we talk about being raised by parents
that hate us and we talk about my wife
um we we were trying to have a baby all
year and she had we had a second
miscarriage
we lost another baby but we're still
trying
right
she might take acupuncture
yeah i might need your ladies yes we
might need your acupuncture person
marina del rey yeah
what's going on what's that mushroom and
[ __ ] you over there pondering your
decision like it's like signing the
marines just eat the [ __ ] thing
i'm over eating pieces by myself with no
water
it's like go ahead inhale that [ __ ]
monster
we're going deep into the murky water
deep it's november 6th it's election
week
here we go drink the thing drink the
thing now don't let drink drink drink
don't [ __ ] there you go there you go
this poor bastard i loved it
ladies and gentlemen a [ __ ] soldier
that's a boss he's a soldier he's an
american soldier
he came around at the right time there's
no blow
there's no where's the rest of it let me
see you either i don't know i don't want
no stories you should
pop the eyeball that's the rest of the
night right there we'll put on [ __ ]
black sabbath
volume four i'll make your head grow you
understand me you don't know what hit
you next thing you know there's spiders
on your scalp
you got a lot of [ __ ] going on man
and you deserve a lot of [ __ ] that's why
i was telling you to chase that anarchy
pilot it just got released somebody said
that that dude they're releasing two
spin-offs i guess brad pitt's doing the
father yeah he's playing now they're
doing pre yeah and then they're doing
the mice you're mine i'm waiting i've
been lifting weights
you've been renting a motorcycle not yet
you got to rent a motorcycle nothing
going to pull you on the truck you like
an [ __ ]
you got to get into it you know what i'm
saying rent the guy tell you to take it
to a park where there's no cars and just
make believe like it's you and learn how
to drink and like that you know when
they got the part in the room and they
go when you read and knock them dead
they'll go can you ride a motorcycle you
know what are you [ __ ] kidding me how
are you i'm even evil's cousin
and that's it but you're prepared
because they're going to ask you and
then if they really like you they'll
hire you but then they gotta shoot you
getting pulled on the truck
and you like make believe that you see
the trees chips yeah you're all relaxed
if i'm doing 60 i'm on this [ __ ]
i'm not singing [ __ ] songs you
but that's what it looks like so it kind
of looks shitty so i told you felipe get
prepared get prepared to fall off the
bike be a little stumped man too we'll
get you a couple of yards extra put some
knee padding on you you're mexicans you
guys don't get workman's comp it's over
i'm ready you don't need it you don't
give a [ __ ] you'll take a fall you'll be
the next morning
bam
like rodrigo rodrigo i tell that story
on stage what the uh you fell off the
roof the ladder oh my god
rodrigo that was one of the funniest
conversations
i've ever had on a phone call
in my life
and i
thought i've been part of some funny
conversations on the fall
because you called me like nothing
happened and then you broke it down from
it you fell off the ladder and i'm like
is this a dream nothing really happened
to i went to this fool's house with a
big ass bubble in the back of it i took
a bomb but it was like he had like six
months of bad luck
like he lost an ear
a battery found his finger a battery
fell on your finger and then you fell
off the [ __ ] roof and when you're
telling me the story
i said a prayer for you got off the
phone but i'm like what's going on with
[ __ ] rodrigo
like who falls off her roof and is
walking around
yeah man and then uh that [ __ ] didn't
blow up blow up so i went to this
fullest house and i took a bong rip and
i coughed i guess the blood vessels
because you know it was like i got
kicked in the back by a [ __ ] horse
but then i took that hit and that [ __ ]
[ __ ] just started expanding like a
lot
yeah it was just all the blood just
[ __ ] rushing dude and then i had to
get that [ __ ] leaked out and i was it
was just a contusion you know man at the
end of the day we know each other a long
time guys long [ __ ] calmly [ __ ]
yeah man
[ __ ] it went by fast
different you know what i'm saying
[ __ ]
can i plug my shows for flappers is that
cool [ __ ] no what do you think this is a
plug factory
let's just show a flap a little bit it's
uh november 21st we're gonna start it
out on a monday at the yoohoo room in
burbank okay 8pm and then uh 29th in
december that's my show at flappers in
uh claremont yeah i'm going to try to do
a monthly show there so we're going to
be the youtube room is a nice room
to set the [ __ ] the uh room is a very
nice room i'm doing valentine's day then
nine o'clock awesome
anti-show she called me up barbara and i
said yeah
you know who gives a [ __ ] it's why did
there was no expectations to her that
little yoga room is gold
you know all you need is 30 people to
get the party started oh hell yeah i'm
not big you know i don't want to [ __ ]
sell 200 tickets on a tuesday night
that's too much stress 30 tickets we all
go back everybody eats a [ __ ]
appetizer
boom you go home you got nice
underground parking you're next to
barney's [ __ ] you give mama a cocktail
and take her home and give her a
stabbing
and nobody gets their [ __ ] feelings
hurt man it's a nice easy place all
these little clubs around this we don't
have the leisure that we used to have
we don't have those
dog i cut my teeth on those [ __ ]
rooms hell yeah man from the brave bull
to
coyotes to your wild coyote to the
tuesday and wednesday the hop
the the first time i went to the hop
somebody gave me blow
i thought i was a [ __ ] movie star
like i drove straight home i didn't stop
to get nothing nothing
the first time i went to the hop because
i met these guys on the wednesday night
show
at the wall coyote something it was
something and then you said what are you
doing tomorrow night meet us at this
place
place was [ __ ] packed
i went up there and talked about blow
and they went [ __ ] crazy and as i was
walking out there was like a tent in the
back
and one of the guys pulled me and put
something in my hand it was a big old
rock
i got in that car with 40 in my pocket a
rock of coke and a pack of smokes what
you ain't stopping what i'm driving in
the right-hand lane i'm doing the speed
limit you know what i'm saying
i'm in no rush i don't have to do
nothing outside the ordinary i just got
to get the [ __ ] home
and man but those rooms that place casa
latina i remember when those rooms those
rooms dried up
right as i stopped doing coke
and those rooms are what fed my
addiction without nobody really knowing
because any check i would get i would
give to my wife
but those sixty seventy dollars remember
when you go out
three times a week even if you're
fighting for your life when you go out
three times a week and you come home
with 70 dollars a night that's 210 bro
that's 840 on the street that's if you
don't do an extra on the show or
some paul rodriguez don't call you to
open from for a small nickel
you know what i'm saying that means in
l.a i was hustling
making [ __ ] 800 a month i mean in 20s
going home putting gas money stopping at
uh
the taco place off the five
the one that mexicans don't like but i
[ __ ] love and do you know vfw for
gilbert the bfw good ass tacos across
the street oh my god food truck [ __ ]
tacos league you're heading in the blue
leg movie and uh it's called uh
delaware
delaware right that's where where he
lives delaware we used to go down there
for forty dollars for the vfw yeah but
the tacos were 50 [ __ ] cents
wilmington wilmington
not delaware woman big wilma shout out
and then we used to go to one other
place where it was scary the stage used
to shake
on like wednesday nights in west covina
it was out there dawg i remember me you
eight of us would go on stage for 40
bucks
and then we had to play some pasadena
for a while yeah accused cues
wow the [ __ ] years have gone brother
we're still in the game
your brother tapped out then
and then tuesday nights at um that plays
in hollywood it didn't pay though but it
was a good place to hang out which one
oh man what's it called now it was a
dublin's
doubles i only went to dublin's two
times me too man i didn't like doubles
that wasn't for me they didn't pay
well it wasn't that they didn't pay it
wasn't on a scene
it wasn't our scene see in those days i
used to get 12 15 12 30 spots at the end
of the comedy store four nights a week
so i had something at 12 30. so i'm
gonna do sit in my house at nine o'clock
at night [ __ ] felipe what's going on
come on down here bro we got something
down here 30 bucks what the [ __ ] 30
bucks is 30 bucks you get there on e
you know saying you got there on e
and you knew we were gonna score the one
place as soon as i walked in my [ __ ]
burrito was waiting under the green pork
burrito i'm never going to lie to nobody
how felipe took care of me in that room
all i had to do was walk in and
sometimes it was not to go container
or something that mexican waiter though
the manager give it to you when am i up
dog three likes
i would go down there with the hunger of
ten men
are you [ __ ] kidding me [ __ ]
peter chen oh my god
you know you have no idea what those
rooms do for you you know until you sit
back while you're doing them you're like
ah 30 bucks who gives a [ __ ] [ __ ] you
you're feeding let me tell you something
say what you want to say about that
early g dog he was giving me 40 bucks
every monday night that dude kept me in
cocaine for years
up there in the bro what was the name of
the rumba room the roma room monday
nights monday nights man come on you say
what the [ __ ] you want to say i love to
kick them in the stomach too
at the end i gotta put my hand down and
go dawg for about a year and a half you
don't know what you did
the 40 hours i took on the longest yard
with a 40 game
i had 40 3 cigarettes and a joint it was
i went up there to do money i was
leaving tuesday at 10.
when that limo came to get me and i had
forty dollars you know what i felt like
because i got to tip this [ __ ] guy i
had to give him a 20. bug i got 20 i got
on the plane with like [ __ ] you know
movie stars and i got a 20 two camel
lights which i was holding on to dear
[ __ ] life you understand me
i wouldn't smoke those things unless
there was an earthquake i was like one
of those katrina [ __ ]
i had that thing in a baggie and
everything
and i had one joint and i was like i'm
gonna hold on to this [ __ ] thing
and you know watch dog i get to
albuquerque
right away i go to my hotel on the way
out there's checking girls
there's a bunch of girls and then like
if you're in the movie you have to check
in here
and i walk over to the girl and i check
in and she gives me an envelope and i go
what's in the envelope i went like this
she goes no take it up to your room and
read it when you're upstairs and then
bring the contracts back downstairs
i go upstairs to my hotel room i put my
luggage away i set up the sleep apnea
machine
i thought it was a movie contract to
that [ __ ]
i empty the [ __ ] thing out
and there's like a contract
then there's a contract for a rental car
i had a license but i didn't have a
license
you ever been in this situation
like i had a colorado license i was
living in california for eight years
i lost my california colorado license on
a plane like you know after 9 11 all the
[ __ ] [ __ ] so i lost my [ __ ]
license so i didn't have a license
so
you know
how am i going to get this [ __ ] car
didn't even ask me
they even [ __ ] asked me
then there was another envelope and i
listened to that envelope and there was
800 bills
per diem per diem
i walked to that balcony i opened that
[ __ ] up
and i lit that [ __ ] joint like i
owned that hotel
you understand right and i smoked half
of it you know me
i smoked half of that [ __ ] i put
it out i put a cup over it so the wind
would blow it off the balcony because
that's the last joint uncle joey had and
i got a knock at the door
from one of the bellman
and he goes excuse me i have another
contract for you and he gave it to me
goes
by the way i have blueberry something
and something else
and i go what did you just say
and he goes i can smell it in your room
if you needed me
i got blueberry something and something
else i go where can i find you in 10
minutes he goes right downstairs at the
desk
i went right down there with a yardstick
and he gave me a big old bag of this
[ __ ] i was in heaven
you know the first year i got the
longest y'all i didn't work
i didn't work
i went to albuquerque
did a few jumping jacks they had me walk
around and they go just go to the hotel
we'll call you when you need you i would
wake up i would eat with the team and
then go back to my hotel room smoke pot
watch tv wait for them to call if they
wouldn't call by five i just could
doodle over to the set and see what they
were doing
they'd all give me hugs they go you came
at the right time there's dinner
i would eat and then walk back to my
[ __ ] ho that's what i did for the
first week and a half
how crazy and they pay you hell yeah how
[ __ ] crazy is that
[ __ ] crazy as [ __ ] but that's badass
i'm real happy for you felipe you got
shows and you got that chick
right she's hot she's she's always hot
the chick that played the ugly betty
yeah that's her name marika ferrara yeah
she's very nice to you she's very nice
on the set yeah everybody even that guy
from the kids in the hall when you're on
the set can you believe that you were
homeless at one time i can't believe it
man can you imagine if you raised your
hand and said guys before we even do
this you know i saw i smoked crack at
one time
before you start making i said let
everybody know that i ordered um uh
almond hammer baking soda and a big
spoon for room service
one of the funniest stories of all time
though one of the funniest [ __ ]
things i ever heard in my life
one of the funniest calls i ever got in
the monday morning ever whatever that
just threw me off when pete called me
that was one of the [ __ ] like i was
just blown away
that's when i knew the power of felipe
that's why i knew the power of
of drugs and philippe i knew there was
indian blood all my suspicions were
confirmed
he lit the curtain on fire i don't
[ __ ] i'm like what are you talking
about
and pete was a sweetheart pete wasn't
even mad he he got it
and then you went in there and [ __ ]
killed the room on a monday night open
mic
on a three-day binge you couldn't even
see they're still talking about that
[ __ ] set so
it's all around i don't know what i said
man you lit the room on fire two times i
put my name on the list and then i did
oh i went up and did 20 got off then i
told my name again
you know felipe had teamed up that
weekend i forget his name is and i
wouldn't want to say it
felipe teamed up that weekend that with
a kid that was a very interesting kid as
a matter of fact i loved him at one
point in my life
he was an innocent redneck who dog
when you got cocaine
that [ __ ] went off
felipe did he go off he go off he went
off
white dude i love crazy white people
that's why i don't like starbucks that's
why i don't like none of that [ __ ]
if you're going to be white you better
be [ __ ] crazy i want you to be crazy
manager don't come to because i'm not it
makes you like everybody else who gives
a [ __ ]
i like crazy [ __ ] white people i like
rednecks okay yeah i like elvis i like
anything [ __ ] redneck i hate women
because because they're rednecks they
have like like i was telling somebody i
was trying to explain to you the other
day rednecks really run [ __ ] get a copy
of the cma awards whatever they did last
week and first of all they took uh
beyonce off with the white chicks the
dixie chicks sing it i'm not mad about
that that's got nothing to do with me i
didn't give a [ __ ] about that what
happened
that chick went up there
what's her name sh
not the one that's married to mcgraw
not faith hill that [ __ ] is on her own
planet but the other blonde one up there
and she had a dress on a national tv
that was
a quarter inch above that monkey
it looked good out of the dress she
looked beautiful they were saying kind
of stuff that was a little
passe for eight o'clock
like if you drink that you're gonna pee
pee and if you smoke that and you get
the munchies like it was a little like
somebody else wouldn't get away with it
i enjoy country music i don't give a
[ __ ] you know me my wife taped it for
one of the performances and i go why are
you taping for let me watch it and i
watch it for a little while i thought it
was [ __ ] amazing like you know the
quarterback was there they tortured him
yeah and it was a great scene yes it was
rehearsed
but it was still [ __ ] great you know
what i'm saying like at least they they
talk to a quarterback country music they
don't so i like crazy white people
that's what my [ __ ] point is joey
what the [ __ ] point why are you
talking about tv shows [ __ ]
because i love crazy why i'm gonna be
wanting to be crazy
this guy would get crazy crazy there's
two crazy white people in texas there's
that and they're taking boots off either
no
what's her
name monroe
who is that
country singer
no no no no no
it's the other hot one
the other one that sings off the [ __ ]
charts
but uh
so this kid whatever his name was one
time i had a drive from houston
to [ __ ] it was 10 hours
and i remember him telling me dog listen
i'll cover the gas but you gotta cover
the eight ball i'm like
he's like [ __ ] yeah
and when we get there they got two eight
balls waiting for us
he had another white dude that was what
do you when you have a warrant put out
for you because you're married twice
but look at me polygamy damn polygamist
he had the club at this place he was a
magician horrible
but he was coked up from a to z he made
joe diaz look like a [ __ ] like i
didn't have a problem with that
hell yeah i know that guy too
oh that's crazy i love
first crazy white dude i haven't met
there we go looking for that for after
the show in colorado i woke up one
morning and i heard this southern accent
i'm like who the [ __ ] is in my living
room and that was this dude's name was
carl he was making me laugh my [ __ ]
he was arguing people on north carolina
basketball you ain't got nothing to say
he was like where you from california
you're right ucla [ __ ] that way you've
been the last ten he was just dropping
knowledge and i became friends with him
all those years i think i was telling
leah's story one night when
we were in a video store and there was a
guy with a
windbreaker on and he walked in he's
like what's happening man it was a crazy
night last night we got [ __ ] up and
also he's like man i did so much coke
last night there's a guy
with his back towards us
and he could hear the conversation like
oh god what the [ __ ] he goes man [ __ ]
him
he goes i got [ __ ] up last night and
awesome right in front of me he says
picking his nose right
and he takes out this boulder of a snot
with his head attached to it
and he looks at it and he goes
like in his mind
i can see him thinking like what am i
going to do with this thing
and in his mind i could see it and also
he looked back at the dude with the
windbreaker and he just flicked it at
him
and when it hit the windbreaker it went
like
a little thump and i'm like this guy
this guy is originally crazy like i like
those guys this is how this dude in
houston was
if you wanted to go if you wanted to
snort coke
this guy would snort coke he took me to
two places he took me away for two
weekends the one weekend was corpus
christi where they tried to pay us with
coke
weren't you with us marilyn when they
came to the room and i told marilyn to
give me a stash yeah the guy gave us
both like an eight ball and i told
marilyn just give me your stash i'll
give you the two hundred
maryland took a hundred for the eight
ball was [ __ ] yellow
i didn't come home that sunday
i didn't come home till tuesday
maybe wednesday
that's it guys yeah man i'm happy to
[ __ ] see you felipe happy to you too
man so what's left for the year where
are you new year's new year's eve no
show but january 21st i'm at the novo in
downtown l.a okay formerly the no club
nokia
club nokia look at lee look at lee look
at this [ __ ] beauty lenovo what's up
lisa i'm going to indiana with paul
rodriguez lisa okay
november 19th
so you're staying home at the horseshoe
casino you're staying home the whole
month of december yes the last three
weeks
just relaxing relaxing listen you don't
want to be one of those [ __ ] at the
airport ain't nothing worth that
aggravation no man every year you sit
there you go look at these [ __ ] at
the airport i love these agents that
call you i got a tremendous gig for you
on the 26th yeah where is it [ __ ]
alaska
that's where i want to [ __ ] go you
know what i'm saying
i got this game at 27th ford in detroit
if you want it huh they'll tell you i
have a gig december 27. it's a wendy's
hell no huh no like they'll ask you i
have a gig for your december 27th and
you don't want to follow me i'm done for
a gig and i gotta cancel it's my wife's
birthday
i'll tell you what if i don't cancel my
wife ain't gonna say nothing to me but
you know what
i got 360 other [ __ ] days to work
even if we just walk hand to hand and go
to the movies and come home at 8 o'clock
we get babysitters till 10 we never make
it
that's how old you are when you get a
babysitter you go to dinner you look at
each other and go [ __ ] this we're going
home
yeah we always have to pay the baby so
like out of embarrassment you know what
i'm saying like
what are we gonna do but even if i just
do that with my wife i can't just get up
and go so i gotta call the [ __ ] agent
tomorrow i didn't realize when i booked
the [ __ ] gig this is my wife's
birthday but what are you gonna [ __ ]
yeah
we have a rabbit sitter
we have a pet rabbit and we go out of
town sometime we leave it at a rabbit
theater and hangs out with all the
rabbits hey you know me
just shout out to slippers
just make sure lee don't get his hand on
that rabbit lee bumps into animals like
that
he'll go to the korean town he'll hit
him like
my brother though he just he makes bad
choices look at him
he'll go home and eat hummus on top like
he still goes to subway no my spies tell
me festo's
still goes over the subway it's a
24-hour subway
they see him creeping on lowercase at
two in the morning with slippers and a
robot
with a [ __ ] santa hat you know he
thinks he's slick you don't think i know
he's been seen on mcdonald's
drive-through one night
speaking spanish
lee silent is the rock in gibraltar
nobody else would still stay here this
long he gets [ __ ]
bazzizzled two nights a week two weeks
ago he did that so it took him three
days to recover you understand me he's a
tank of death this kid
they don't even make him like this no
more they don't make him like this no
more the last of the mohicans that's it
he's not even a millennial no more he's
just a regular [ __ ] savage
he used to be a millennial when he met
me he was doing all stupid [ __ ]
going paul hanging out with six people
at a bar like friends this ain't no
episode of friends
now he's alright he's got a girlfriend
he's got a bidet he smokes reefer he
eats edibles he's up to what 1200
milligrams
this all started with a 10 milligram
[ __ ] cookie look where you are now
1200 milligrams you're one of the best
producers in the business
you're a great friend you're a [ __ ]
animal look at you you're gonna eat
another mushroom cap so we can throw
away the bag and the evidence no
oh my dude i'm so [ __ ] up no you know
what do you mean no i'm not you're as
tough as males you don't even know how
[ __ ] up you are you gotta smoke into
the bonget
yeah and that'll calm you down and [ __ ]
you open that for me my fingers are all
[ __ ] up
all right i'd like to thank uh on it on
it's always been there for us since day
one
one of the best products on the market
you know us we can't do nothing for you
on the weight side or the weighted vest
as far as supplements are concerned
it's the best there is from the alpha
brain
to the shroom tech
to the to the to the to the uh what's
the [ __ ] protein shake i like
the um
hemp force hemp force uh chocolate or
cocoa as they have it delicious i love
all that stuff if you don't believe me
try it go to hana go down to the box and
press in church boom and get ten percent
off your [ __ ] oil delivered
right to your door if you get the alpha
brand 100 money back guarantee like i
said lee's got a beautiful watch when
mvmt
contacted me i looked at the i looked at
the website
and i liked the prices and whatnot but
you know what i got a gorilla wrist my
wife bought me a bracelet last year and
i told her don't buy me the [ __ ]
bracelet but she bought it for me and i
told her when she got it for me put it
on my wrist it don't fit that's why i
told you not to get the [ __ ] bracelet
because now i can't get the bracelet
fixed unless i go back to that same
jewelry store in new jersey you know how
hard it is to get to that jewelry store
it's easier to get the [ __ ] marlon
brandon apocalypse now to get to that
[ __ ] jewelry store i was at the light
for [ __ ] four lights one time though
in the middle like it hadn't even turned
not to bergen wine avenue so forget it
so i'm stuck with this [ __ ] thing i
got no problem he even told me mail it
to me and i'll take care of it but
anyway i gave the watch to lily what do
you think so far of your mvmt watch i
love it
it's slick i really i've always liked
black on black that's the one i have i
think it looks great it's very light
it's uh i got it fitted right right to
me it took two seconds it was like 10
bucks they gave you four extra links it
was great mine feels great i love it and
uh gotta
tell us yeah
for people who don't know mvmt
the company was started by two college
kids that wanted to wear stylish watches
but couldn't afford them so they started
their own watch company i mean they
started it from scratch social media the
same way we did with the podcast youtube
radio you name it movement watches start
at just 95 at a department store you're
looking at 400 to 500 for these same
watches again movement watches start at
95
moomin figured out that by selling
online they were able to cut out the
middleman and retail markup and the
retail markup providing the best
possible price for you now if you go to
the website they got classic design it's
quality construction and their style
minimalism they're beautiful they've
sold over 500 000 of these watches in
over 160 countries what we're doing here
for the holidays you're going to get 15
off today
today with free shipping and let's say
the thing don't fit you don't like the
color black it is they're going to give
you free returns by going
mvmtwatches.com
church again
this watch has a great design only look
it's got the red hands it just looks
sharp if you wear blue black or let's
say you're [ __ ] scandinavian you got
the sudden nerds to rail a red suit we
got the watch for you over at
mvmtwatches.com church listen join the
movement we're gonna give you free
shipping and if the watch isn't what you
think we'll give you free returns by
going mvmt
watches dot com slash church it's that
easy again mbmt watches.com
church join the movement get 15 off
today why are you playing with my
feelings all right number two you want a
good night's sleep
my mattress is tremendous you know why i
got a helix sleep you know why because
you're unique you don't walk like
everybody else you don't talk like
everybody else you don't sleep like
everybody else so why is it that your
mattress one size fits all tell me
because a custom mattress will cost you
five to ten thousand dollars until uncle
joey got a hold of you introducing helix
sleep
where you buy a mattress online
customized for you for hundreds of
dollars instead of thousands go to
helix.com answer a few simple questions
based on four key preferences and the
result will be a custom sleep profile
used to build you the most comfortable
matches you'll ever sleep on your
mattress will arrive at the door in
about a week and shipping is 100 free
and for couples helix customizes on each
side of the mattress helix customers
report a 30 improvement in overall sleep
quality you have 100 nights to try it
out and if you don't love it
they'll pick it up for free and give you
100 money back guarantee no questions
asked all right 100 refund no questions
asked this is the mattress that gq
magazine the forbes they're all talking
about
so do me a favor go to helixsleep.com
right now slash joey and get 50 off your
order again that's helixsleep.com
joey
one more time for the cheap seats
helixsleep.com
joey who [ __ ] you think you're messing
with joey bananas hold on i got an itchy
here what are you looking at
at me like i owe you 32 dollars relax
will you he said jokes lee these are
[ __ ] jokes lee what do you like about
blue apron i i love you know what i love
about it it's teaching me to be better
with my time
because you really have to be really
cool quick you have to have everything
ready and you have to it's great i love
it i cooked the what the what i loved
last week and i cooked on periscope is
the crispy chicken i made mashed
potatoes and spicy collard greens i've
never made mashed potatoes before how
good with the collard greens fresh oh my
god they were vegetables were fresh
everything's fresh yeah i had to clean
them clean them and then uh they we
cooked them with uh
oil and
garlic it was amazing oh my god
everybody who eats blue apron i get
emails and people love it and here's the
beauty of it for less than ten dollars a
meal blue apron delivers seasonal
recipes along with proportion
ingredients to make delicious
home-cooked meals blue aprons knows that
when you cook with incredible
ingredients the result is tremendous all
right they got the highest quality
standards for their community suppliers
family run farms and fisheries and
ranches whether it's the japanese ramen
noodles to the wild caught alaskan
salmon or the heirloom tomatoes blue
apron is bringing you the best you want
a diet this is the way to do it right
here right check out this week's menu
and get your first three meals free
with free shipping by going to
blueapron.com
joey again you'll love how good it feels
you'll love how good it tastes and
you're going to create incredible
home-cooked meals with blue apron so
don't wait it's for you the family they
got a family plan they got a two-person
plan you're gonna love what they got to
offer again that's blueapron.com joey
blueapron.com joey hey your career is
hectic you're on the move blue apron is
a better way to cook again
blueapron.com joey either thank blue
apron i'd like to thank helix sleep and
mv mt watchers for sponsoring the
podcast tonight i had to thank felipe
esparza thank you julian [ __ ] rodrigo
torres yeah aka silent bob for stopping
by
what's up fool
lisa how you doing you all right my
brother i'm doing good all right i'll
see you [ __ ]
saturday night at the fox woods casino i
got nothing for you friday night but
sadly i got nothing but love for you
lee's gonna be there we're gonna do the
show and i'm gonna watch mcgregor in
[ __ ] whatever fight and that's that
the way it's gonna be the 18th of
november i'm in the what's the name of
the festival
come and take it come and take a
festival in houston i'm performing
november 18th you got to get a single
day pass for 35 bucks you catch a couple
of great shows but i don't know what
time i go up at 10 o'clock so that means
i think you can watch todd barry at
eight it's a great little festival i'll
either see you [ __ ] in foxwoods
i'll either see you [ __ ] that
uh
the will bettina oh i'll see you
[ __ ] at
the come and take a comedy festival in
houston i'll talk to you guys tuesday
stay black uncle joey loves you what's
up
you